Du kennst das, wenn man jemanden,
einen alten Freund anrufen möchte
und dann macht man das nicht
und dann schiebt man das vor sich her und dann hat man es
irgendwann so lange nicht mehr gemacht,
dass man sich gar nicht mehr traut, weil es irgendwie awkward ist,
weil man sich schon so lange nicht mehr gesprochen hat.
Da gab es von einem Podcast, der glaube ich gar nicht mehr
existiert, ich wette, das haben wir auch so mal
angesprochen,
so irgendein Internet-Podcast von Gimlet Media,
einer von den ersten, den die gemacht haben,
als sie noch existierten, bevor die von Spotify
gekauft wurden vor Jahren.
die haben das Konzept des E-Mail-Debt-Forgiveness-Days eingeführt.
Das, was du gerade meinst mit Anrufen,
wo sie sich bloß auf E-Mails bezogen werden,
wenn du eine Mail in deiner Inbox hast,
die du seit vor Monaten jetzt beantworten sollen,
aber da ist so viel Zeit vergangen,
dass jetzt zu antworten richtig awkward wäre,
gibt es quasi diesen Feiertag einmal im Jahr
und da darfst du schuldfrei alte E-Mails beantworten.
Ach, beantworten?
Ja, du darfst jetzt beantworten.
Hi, ich beantworte dir.
Dann kriegt jeder so eine Flut von altem Mist quasi.
Genau, genau.
Aber du musst dich zumindest nicht schuldig fühlen
und alle Leute müssen wissen, dass das existiert,
damit sie auch nicht das komisch finden.
Fängt jede E-Mail an mit einem Link zu dieser Gimlet-Seite,
wo das erklärt wird.
Und dann einen Tag später schalten die da Werbung drauf
und denken sich so, muhahaha.
Gimlet, die gibt es echt schon lange nicht mehr.
Das ist ja auch schon pre-pandemic gewesen, glaube ich.
Oder?
Das ist möglich.
Also ich muss sagen, ich muss mich wirklich in
Ultraschall erstmal wieder ein bisschen reinfuchsen.
Ich glaube auch Version 4 ist gar nicht mehr aktuell.
Ich muss das nochmal neu aufsetzen.
Komplett von vorne.
Meinst du, wird der weitest du wie bei Version 6 oder so?
Ja, vermutlich.
8.
Ich habe hier auch vorhin ein paar Ansichten gefunden, die ich noch nie benutzt habe.
Es gibt nicht nur Routing, es gibt auch Wiring.
Dann hast du so eine schicke...
Aber ich will ja jetzt gar nicht in dem Moment, wo wir aufzeichen, aufklicken.
Das hat vorhin so lange gedauert, dass ich das angekriegt habe.
Das ist gefährlich.
Aber zum Schluss war es dann doch das Betriebssystem.
Hi, Kilian.
Hey, Hendrik.
Mensch, wie geht's dir?
Oh, mir geht's prima. Und dir?
Ja, super. Also ich freue mich voll, dass wir das immer wieder machen.
Aber wir lassen es auch gar nicht zu sehr thematisieren,
dass wir jetzt schon seit anderthalb Jahren keine neue Folge mehr aufgenommen haben.
Kennst du das, wenn man seinen Blog neu aufsetzt?
Ich habe das mindestens dreimal gemacht.
Und dann machst du einen Blog darüber,
dass du deinen Blog neu aufgesetzt hast, worauf er diesmal basiert.
Und dann schreibst du wieder nichts.
Ja, und dann drei Jahre später ist der nächste Post, oh, ich habe dieses neue CMS oder diesen neuen Stack entdeckt und jetzt läuft alles darauf und wie toll das doch ist.
Das kann ich endlich wieder bloggen.
Kein Inhalt.
Drei Jahre später.
Ich glaube, man kann ja über Medium sagen, was man will.
Also man kann sehr viel über Medium sagen, vor allem, dass der Inhalt sehr Medium ist.
Genau das haben wir auch schon gesagt.
Aber, ich glaube, wenn man sich das Problem des selber Hostens einmal vom Hals geschafft hat, dann kann man sich endlich auf den Inhalt konzentrieren.
Ja, aber mich würde es ankotzen, wenn ich auf Medium wäre und die Plattform dann immer beschissener wird, dann würde ich da auch nichts mehr schreiben.
Das ist wie dasselbe, wenn ich mein Stack nicht mehr mag nach einer langen Zeit. Dann habe ich da auch keinen Bock mehr. Null Motivation.
Deswegen haben wir jetzt auch extra unsere Subreddit gelöscht.
Weil bei uns sind jetzt auch noch sexy Bilder von John Oliver erlaubt.
Dieser ganze Abfuck, das macht mich so fertig.
Was ist denn alles kaputt gegangen, seitdem wir das letzte Mal geredet haben?
Also das ist ja offiziell die erste Folge seit dem Krieg.
Ich dachte ja vorhin, als du das Bett aufgemacht hast,
dass das das Bett von der vorherigen Folge war
und wir damals schon den Witz gemacht hatten.
Nee, das ist die erste Folge.
Oh shit, oh, jetzt verstehe ich es ja.
Oh, scheiße.
Und der läuft immer noch.
Und seitdem sind noch andere Sachen passiert,
wie zum Beispiel dein Fahrrad wurde zweimal geklaut.
Zweimal? Stimmt.
Echt? War das andere Mal
vor der letzten Folge? Kann sein.
Vielleicht. Das weiß ich mir gar nicht mehr.
Aber das letzte Mal ist jetzt erst zwei Wochen her und das nervt
mich immer noch sehr.
Vor allem, weil ich das AirTag selber wiedergefunden
habe. Sind die jetzt schlau genug,
dass sie das AirTag rausnehmen?
Zum einen müssen sie nicht mehr schlau genug sein, weil die
AirTags ja die nervige Angewohnheit haben, auf sich
aufmerksam zu machen, akustisch.
Ich glaube, AirTags sind wirklich nicht dafür
gedacht, dass du was Geklautes wiederbekommst,
sondern nur, wenn du es versaubeutelst.
Ich werde mir aus einem AirTag, wenn ich ein neues Fahrrad gekauft habe, dann den Lautsprecher raus operieren,
was ja eigentlich ein bisschen sketchy ist, weil dann begibst du dich in die Gefilde von diesen weirden Stalker-Menschen.
Das ist dann ein Stalker-Tag.
Ja, aber ich will es ja explizit fürs Stalken von meinem Fahrrad benutzen.
Also ich checke es ja nicht jemandem in die Tasche, sondern ich will einfach nur...
Hast du Konzent von deinem Fahrrad dafür?
Ja, behaupte ich einfach mal.
Also dein neues Fahrrad wirst du explizit danach aussuchen, dass es dir dann...
Dass es consented?
Dass es consented, ja.
Ja, vielleicht nenne ich es einfach consent.
ist ein komischer Name
mein aktuelles Fahrrad heißt ja Unreliable
aber es ist immer noch am Fahren
aber welches Fahrrad ist dir denn jetzt
geklaut worden? Mein Gravel Bike, mein schönes
Fahrrad. Wie hieß das? Steven
weiß von der Marke Stevens Fahrs war nicht
so richtig kreativ
ich war heute im Fahrradladen
es gibt schöne neue Sachen
glaube ich
zufällig ein blaues Stevens Gravel Bike
ich glaube in dem Laden wo ich war verkaufen
überhaupt keine gebrauchten Fahrräder
aber vielleicht, ich meine,
so gebraucht war es ja noch nicht.
Nee, Ende
Sommer letztes Jahr gekauft
und letztens erst
vor einem Monat
grob oder so zum Service gebracht
und weil die ersten tausend Kilometer
runter waren, nochmal alles schön auffrischen lassen
und ich habe eine Schraube kaputt
gemacht, die haben sie mir nochmal neu gebohrt gehabt
also eine
ja, ein Loch für eine Schraube
wie nennt man das? Egal
auf jeden Fall ist es wieder ganz gewesen
die Bremsenummer neu. Das tut mir so leid.
Ich hoffe, die Versicherung zahlt, aber das weiß ich
erst in etwas über einer Woche, weil
die meint, ich muss drei Wochen warten
und dann wollen sie eine Bestätigung vom Fundbüro.
Und ich so, kriege ich eine Bestätigung vom Fundbüro?
Und dann schaue ich auf die Webseite von Dresdner
Fundbüro und da steht dann eine explizit eine Section.
Falls Sie hier sind, weil Sie eine Bestätigung für Ihre Versicherung
haben wollen, schicken Sie uns bitte dieses
Formular als Fax oder irgendwie sonst wie.
Kostet so und so viel Geld.
Natürlich.
Adding
Das war ja dann eher der Fakt, dass ich mich für das
SZ-Fahrradfest angemeldet habe.
Und an dem Tag... SZ-Fahrradfest, wenn ihr
akronomisierbar treffen wollt,
dann fahrt die 100 Kilometer mit.
Ja genau, wir fahren nach
nicht nach Meißen, sondern
nach Riesa. Nach Riesa, stimmt, nach Riesa und zurück.
An dem Tag, wo das
Fahrrad geklaut wurde, kam natürlich der Brief
mit diesem Trikot und der Startnummer
vom SZ-Fahrrad. Das war
adding insult to injury.
Ich bin mal gespannt, mit was für einem Fahrrad du dann fahren wirst.
Im schlimmsten Fall leih ich dir eins aus.
Ich habe schon überlegt, ob es lustig wäre,
mit so einem DVB-Mobi-Bike mitzufahren.
Ja, das werden einige machen.
Echt?
Ja, das ist gar nicht so ungewöhnlich.
Da habe ich ein paar von gesehen.
Was ich überraschend fand,
das erste Mal, als ich vor zwei, drei Jahren
einmal eine längere Tour mitgefahren bin,
ist einer mit einem, wie hieß diese Bude,
wo du dir so ein Fahrrad leasen konntest?
Ach, Swapfeeds.
Da ist einer mit einem Elektro-Swapfeeds gefahren.
Die gab es.
Und die arme Sau ist dann irgendwo im Elbsandsteingebirge,
wo es ein ganzes Stück bergauf geht,
war der Akku alle.
Du musst ja in dieses schwere Ding einen Hang hochschieben.
Okay, da hätte ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, deswegen habe ich dann immer gefragt,
wenn ich Freunde gesehen habe,
die mit dem Elektrofahrrad bei so einem Fahrradfest mitmachen,
ob sie das auch aufgeladen haben.
Das haben sie manchmal nicht so verstanden,
wie ich es gemeint habe.
Aber es war immer lieb gemeint.
So, was ist denn alles noch Cooles passiert?
Lass uns aber etwas Fachliches reden.
Wir können kurz über die Reddit-Situation,
weil du sie vorhin schon angesprochen hast, quatschen.
Also Twitter im Arsch.
Stimmt, das ist ja auch seitdem passiert.
Facebook ist wirklich vieler alt.
Das war aber schon längst davor in der letzten Folge.
Und jetzt auch noch Reddit.
Was ist passiert, Karian?
Also die Cory Doctorow hatte mal so einen schönen Begriff ins Leben gerufen.
Entschittification.
Das bezeichnet, wie Online-Plattformen auf dem Weg zur Gewinnmaximierung immer beschissener werden.
Also wortwörtlich Entschittification.
und genau das hat Reddit jetzt auch gemacht.
Die haben festgestellt, also laut CEO, wie heißt er, Steve Huffman,
bringt Reddit noch keinen Gewinn ein,
was erstaunlich ist für die Länge an Zeit,
die Reddit mittlerweile schon existiert.
Mein Account habe ich seit 15 Jahren knapp oder so.
Und jetzt haben sie halt den Entschluss gefasst vor sehr kurzer Zeit,
dass sie Third-Party-Clients und generell auch alles,
dass irgendwie die API benutzt zur Kasse beten wollen.
Was erstmal von sehr vielen Third-Party-Clients sehr begrüßt wurde,
weil das sinnvoll ist für das Weiterleben der Plattform,
weil sie so ein bisschen dann den Contract formalisieren können,
den sie ja eigentlich mit Reddit haben,
weil die API an vielen Stellen beschissen ist
und sie die Hoffnung haben, dass das auch neue Features mit reinbringt,
wie beispielsweise Polls und Chat.
Also wenn man zahlt, ist man Kunde und dann kann man auch Sachen verlangen.
Eben, und nicht unbedingt verlangen,
Oder zumindest begründete Hoffnung haben auf Weiterentwicklung, die bisher nicht so wirklich existiert.
Und dann hat sich Reddit dazu entschieden, die Preise erstmal nicht mitzuveröffentlichen.
Die sollten dann kurze Zeit später folgen.
Und einen Monat später haben sie dann die Preise veröffentlicht und die waren einfach abgrundtief lächerlich.
Ich hab's nicht mehr ganz im Kopf, aber ich glaub, es waren 24 Cent für 1000 Requests oder so, 1000 API-Requests.
Was also jenseits von Gut und Böse ist.
und der Apollo-Entwickler Christian Selig
hat das halt dann mal grob kurz gerechnet.
Der ist auch einer der Leute, die am meisten
24 Cent pro 1000 Requests.
Genau. Ich habe
überhaupt keine Ahnung, in was für einer
Range eine
sinnvolle Bezahlung.
Ja, so vielleicht so. Also ein Zehntel davon
wäre schon teuer.
Christian Selig
hatte, wie gesagt, mal kurz gerechnet gehabt, was das für
ihn an Kosten ausmacht. Er ist der Entwickler
von der populärsten Reddit-App
Apollo, also der populärsten
Third-Party-Client auf iOS.
Das ist generell der Polaristik, soweit ich weiß.
Und er müsste
Reddit 20 Millionen US-Dollar
im Jahr zahlen bei den Preisen.
Das wäre für Reddit super.
Jedes Jahr. Reddit, eine Firma, die letztes Jahr
erst malig 100 Millionen Dollar Gewinn gemacht
hat, wollen von einem Third-Party-
Entwickler, wo sie immer wieder sagen,
dass Third-Party-Client ja keine Sau nutzt, wollen sie von
einem Third-Party-Entwickler 20 Millionen haben.
Klar, natürlich.
Und er hat das auch mal sehr transparent durchgerechnet,
von einem Pro-Nutzer verdient, Pro-Nutzer
auf ihrer Plattform und sie verlangen halt ungefähr
das 20- bis 30-fache von ihm.
Also, ich meine, es gibt
genügend Wege, wie man das sinnvoll hätte angehen können,
aber das ist halt kein Preis, den sie
realistisch haben wollen, das ist literally
eine Fuck-You-Rechnung. Sie zeigen ihm
und allen anderen Third-Party-Entwicklern und
Entwicklerinnen einen riesigen Stinkefinger
und sagen, wir wollen euch nicht mehr auf der Plattform haben.
Man kann das so interpretieren, dass das bewusst als...
Es ist sehr bewusst, definitiv.
Absolut. Das ist gar keine Frage.
dahinter. Auch die restliche Kommunikation
von Reddit, die Christian haufenweise
Wörter in den Mund gelegt haben.
Zigerweise hat er seine Telefonate
mit Reddit aufgenommen, was er darf, weil das in Kanada
erlaubt ist, wenn eine Seite des
Gesprächs consentet und
hat die halt veröffentlicht mit Beweisen, dass
Reddit halt aktiv lügt und Steve Huffman,
also der CEO, scheiße behauptet
über ihn, also wirklich aktiv.
Christian hat es als
career-ending lies, potentially career-ending
lies bezeichnet, was der über ihn veröffentlicht
und es ist halt einfach Kacke.
Man merkt halt richtig, wie die Plattform
jetzt aktiv in den Keller fährt.
Und Reddit hatte halt Anfang des Jahres noch behauptet,
dass sie keine Pläne haben, die API dieses Jahr
zu monetarisieren. Offensichtlich
Bullshit. Dann haben sie halt auch noch diese Pläne
ausgepackt. Und dann haben,
ich glaube, Steve Huffman hatte sogar irgendwie mal gesagt,
oder Reddit hatte gesagt, dass sie kein,
also genau, stimmt, die wollten keinerlei,
ich habe keinen Fall das Pricing
so beschissen, wie Twitter macht. Mit Twitter hat der genau das selbe Problem
gehabt. Die haben absurde Preise von Third-Party-Clients
verlangt und die sind alle eingestampft worden quasi.
Manche haben jetzt ein zweites Leben als Mastodon.
Ja, stimmt.
Ja, das, wie heißt Ivory,
die, was vorher
Tweetbot war.
Tweetbot, ja, Tweetbot, genau.
Von Tabbots.
Aber sicherlich haben die einen Bruchteil
der Kundschaft auf der Plattformgröße.
Also der Bubble fühlt sich natürlich groß genug an,
aber allgemein
wären die wahrscheinlich happy, wenn die,
keine Ahnung, 5% der Kundschaft haben,
die sie auf Twitter hatten.
Jedenfalls
mir anscheinend auch noch großer Elon Musk Fan
und ist sehr überzeugt davon,
wie Elon mit, oder Space Karen
mit Twitter umgegangen ist.
Space Karen?
So hatte Dings die auch bezeichnet.
Zeitschlag auf dem Mobile-Kampp letztens.
Die hatte von Space Karen gesprochen.
Fand ich sehr sympathisch. Der Begriff ist ja allgemein
bekannt, aber ist ein guter
passender Begriff.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, auf jeden Fall läuft das jetzt alles richtig scheiße.
Richtig schön fand ich auch noch den Move, das haufenweise
Subreddits jetzt
entweder zugemacht hatten
oder halt ein paar Sonderregeln eingeführt haben,
wie zum Beispiel die großen Subreddits wie Rpix,
die nur noch sexy Fotos von John Oliver
zulassen. Dann haben sie sich
auf NSFW geschaltet.
Dann haben sie sich auf NSFW
geschaltet, was den netten Nebeneffekt hat,
dass Reddit diese Subreddits nicht mehr mit Werbung
monetarisieren kann.
Und Reddit hat jetzt
haufenweise Mods
von großen Subs
die Modrechte entzogen, teilweise sogar die Accounts
gesperrt und macht jetzt quasi die feindliche
Übernahme und das
schlägt halt an allen Seiten scheiße auf,
logischerweise. Also die Plattform ist quasi
im Arsch jetzt. Also ich möchte behaupten, ist
Reddit nicht sogar älter als
all die anderen Social Networks?
Dass das überhaupt als Social Networks zählt, ist mir
auch irgendwie neu. Ich finde es auch kein Social Network.
Aber man kann halt einander
folgen und... Ja, aber das
macht quasi niemand. Also keine Ahnung, vielleicht machen das Leute.
Aber eigentlich ist es doch schon
seit 20 Jahren auch so ein Forum
gewesen. Ja, ich würde eher in die Kategorie
der Foren mitzählen, weil
die Kommentare sind, die Plattformen sind halt die Kommentare.
Also es gibt
sicherlich auch Original Content auf Reddit,
aber die meisten Leute, also Reddit ist dafür da,
dass du ja Content postest,
du hast einen Link, postest den und Leute
kommentieren das. Es sollte die Kommentarspeite des
Internets sein. Und die sind ja damals auch
gigantisch geworden, nachdem Dig sich sein
eigenes Grave gedickt hatte.
Und das macht Reddit jetzt auch.
Toll. Danke.
Steve. Ich bin ein Arschloch.
Ich mochte Reddit.
Also nicht Steve des Fahrrads.
Na, na, ja.
Jetzt haben wir schon zwei schlimme Themen mit Steve.
Steven heißt das Fahrrad.
Hieß das Fahrrad.
Ja, ja.
Nee, aber du wolltest tolle Themen seit den letzten
halben Jahren. Das ist kein tolles Thema.
Das macht mich aktiv traurig.
Ich habe vielleicht viel zu viel Zeit auf dieser Plattform
verbracht und es ist gut für meine Mental Health,
wenn das wegstirbt, aber ich finde es scheiße, weil
will entscheiden, weil ich das nicht mehr nutze.
Nee, also abends, wenn man das Gehirn schon so halb
abgeschaltet hat, noch so ein bisschen in irgendwas
rumswipen, finde ich eigentlich,
da ist eigentlich Reddit irgendwie super für gewesen,
weil es ist nicht nur Shorts,
irgendwie jede App, weißt du noch, als wir den Witz gemacht haben,
jede App hat jetzt Stories,
so 2022 kam so
dazu, jede App hat jetzt Shorts
und ich denke mir so,
YouTube hat beides, die haben Shorts und Stories.
Ja, es ist doch,
sind nicht das gleiche? Ich weiß es nicht,
es sind auch bloß Cross-Postings von
TikTok. Du siehst halt überall dieses TikTok-Jingle
hinten dran.
Und irgendwie, das ist so
captivating und brain-destroying,
deswegen ist
Reddit irgendwie schon was Schöneres. Da sind immer mal
einfach bloß Bilder. Ja, und es gibt
voll die tollen, sehr positiven
Nischen-Communities, gerade die
3D-Printing-Community und der
3D-Printing und dann Functional Prints, die habe ich
sehr hart frequentiert.
Und ja,
aber sie müssen ja nicht tot sein. Es gibt
ja coole Alternativen, die jetzt
natürlich sehr großen Zulauf haben. Wir hatten das ja
mit dem Twitter-Exodus damals mitbekommen.
Also Twitter-Exodus haben wir eventuell auch noch nicht thematisiert,
aber das müssen wir auch nicht mehr machen. Wir müssen sie nicht die letzten
anderthalb Jahre nachholen. Aber danach
sind wir irgendwie alle auf Mastodon gegangen.
Aber ich möchte behaupten, bei Mastodon
geht auch dieser Hype wieder ein Stückchen zurück.
Aber es ist ja auch gesund, wenn
das ein bisschen wieder abfällt. Ja, ich hatte ein bisschen
gehofft, dass irgendwie jeder sich alle
irgendwie ein
Sub-Mastodon aufmachen.
Und dass jetzt einfach, dass
Das sind eigene Instanzen.
Ach so.
Dass jetzt diese Fed-Diversifizierung
dadurch eintritt, aber stattdessen
sind eher größere Instanzen
gentrifiziert worden
und sowas wie Chaos Social hat
einfach mal
das Neuregistrieren komplett gestoppt.
Legitim, so wie Jabba C3D2.
Jabba? Wie hieß das?
War das jetzt C3D2?
C3D2.
Genau, die hatten ja auch damals zugemacht.
legitim. Es ist halt das Problem,
du willst nicht diese große Instanz sein,
du willst nicht die Hauptinstanz sein.
Es sei denn, du bist mastodon.social, dann möchtest
du es offenbar machen. Anscheinend. Aber es ist
ja auch legitim, wenn sie eine Anlaufstelle
bieten wollen und
du nicht Leute schiebst auf irgendwelche
in Anführungsstrichen potenziell sketchy
andere Instanz, beziehungsweise
die Leute dazu ermutigt, sie natürlich umzuschauen,
aber du bietest ihnen trotzdem
diese Plattform.
Ich würde gerne wissen, was das
kostet, mastodon.social zu betreiben,
Und wie sie es finanziert ist, habe ich noch nicht so richtig verstanden gehabt.
Aber Mastodon.social ist ein zumindest in Deutschland ansässiges Unternehmen.
Sie sind eine GGMBH, eine gemeingültige GGMBH.
Bei Mastodon war es zumindest spannend, dass es so eine gigantische Anzahl von Clients gibt,
die allerdings alle fast gleich heißen.
Es gibt mindestens zwei, die tut heißen, eins mit Ausrufezeichen hinten dran und eins ohne.
Es bietet sich halt an, irgendwie
in die domänen-spezifische Sprache
abzusteigen für einen App-Namen.
Welche App benutzt du zurzeit?
Ich nutze Ivory,
was halt auch ein domänen-spezifischer Name ist.
Ja, aber es klingt wenig,
es heißt nicht Must oder
Odon oder Masto
oder Mast. Gibt es Odon?
Keine Ahnung, welche heißen nicht. Die heißen auch fast alle wie Derivate
von dem Wort Mast. Ja, ja. Mastodon oder Tut.
Oder Tut.
Oder Tutzilla oder was anderes.
Und Ivory klingt zumindest,
Das klingt zwar irgendwie auch nicht politisch correct, aber
ist zumindest ein eigener Name.
Wusstest du, dass es Elefanten gibt
in Afrika, die
dadurch, dass jetzt Menschen
jahrzehntelang
Elefantenstoßzähne geraubt haben
und Elefanten getötet haben, die
große Stoßzähne hatten?
Die haben überhaupt keine mehr.
Es gibt männliche Elefanten komplett ohne Stoßzähne.
Wir haben aktiv die Evolution
vorangetrieben.
Witzigerweise habe ich
das Story meinem Taxifahrer erzählt.
und dann ist die Unterhaltung sehr
anstrengend geworden, weil er mir die ganze Zeit hat
versucht zu erklären, dass die Evolution ja
eine Lüge ist.
Mit Taxifahren sollte man gar nicht reden.
Der Typ war so anstrengend.
Gott sei Dank waren wir nur noch
10 Minuten von zu Hause entfernt, aber
holy fuck war das anstrengend.
Don't get me started on Taxifahrer.
Für die Jungen alle Taxifahrer da draußen.
Ihr seid bestimmt ganz toll.
Die Taxifahrer, die während ihrer Arbeit
jetzt diesen Podcast hören.
Wenn du diesen Podcast hörst, dann bist du einer von den guten Taxi-Panen.
Was hast du in der letzten Zeit Cooles gemacht?
Bist du noch am iVoice entwickeln?
Tatsächlich ganz frisch, nicht mehr so wirklich.
Nein.
Also wir haben auf Arbeit, habe ich überhaupt nicht gesagt, wo ich arbeite?
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht mehr aktuell.
Man muss auch in Betracht ziehen, dass sich in den letzten anderthalb Jahren die wirtschaftliche Lage sehr verändert hat
und wir alle wahrscheinlich froh sein können, dass wir überhaupt draußen waren.
Februar 22 war jetzt eine Folge.
Nee, ich hab erst...
Quatsch mal, wir haben gerade 2023.
Anyway, die Leute wissen es eh nicht, ja.
Ich muss ja überlegen, welches Jahr wir gerade haben.
Ich meine, es gibt so Leute, die...
Oh, es gibt eine neue Folge akronomisierbar.
Ich muss erst mal alle 50, 53 Folgen von vorher noch mal hören,
um caught up zu sein.
Also wenn du diese Person bist, Hut ab.
Dann schreib uns doch mal bitte,
was wir in den letzten Folgen schon erwähnt haben.
Ich hab vorhin nachgeschaut.
Das Schiff des Tesors war in der letzten Folge Thema.
Ja.
Krass.
Weißt du überhaupt noch, was das war?
Ja, klar. Das Schiff, wo du halt alles austauschst.
Aber warum sind wir da drauf gekommen?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Es ging um das Schiff von Jeff Bezos.
Ach stimmt, der hatte so einen Unfall gebaut.
Egal, das Thema können wir jetzt nicht darauf ausgaben.
Hört euch die Folge von letztem Jahr mal.
Ah, geil.
Das ist jetzt die Folge akronisierbar 2023.
Vielleicht auch 2024.
Mal schauen.
Nee, ich habe auf Arbeit, ich bin bei so einem Dresdner Robotics-Unternehmen mittlerweile.
Im Chat habe ich das aber schon mal erwähnt gehabt.
Und wir hatten bisher eine iOS-App, wo du Roboter mit gesteuert hast.
So eine iPad-App.
Dann wurden iPads zu teuer.
Genau, daran ist gescheitert.
Nee, nee.
Wir haben uns entschieden, jetzt ein bisschen was anderes zu machen oder ein bisschen anders das Problem anzugehen.
Und ich habe einfach mal vor ein paar Wochen exemplarisch oder experimentell versucht, eine React-App zu bauen.
Hat mega Spaß gemacht und jetzt sieht alles danach aus,
als ob das der neue Stack wird, auf dem wir arbeiten.
Ach, du hattest experimentell schon mal mit React angefangen?
Also ich hatte angefangen, Web-Technologien auszuprobieren,
weil wir so ein bisschen in der Luft gehangen haben für eine Woche.
Und ich habe mich dann auch ein bisschen auf Vue eingeschossen gehabt
und dann hat mir ein Kollege gesagt, nee, React ist viel geiler.
Und ich so, nee, das ist von Facebook, das kann nicht cool sein.
Dann habe ich mir zu Hause React angeschaut und gemerkt,
oh, das ist ja super cool.
weil das genau wie SwiftUI ist
Nee, SwiftUI ist genau wie Real
Ja, das mag ja sein, aber
das kommt mir halt alles super bekannt vor, es ist super
verständlich, es ist super zugänglich
und wenn du online dazu was suchst irgendwie
versuchst irgendwelche Guides zu finden
oder Docs zu lesen, dann steht da ganz fett
hier ist alles, was du sonst kennst, diese
deklarative UI, ja, ja, ich
weiß, das finde ich cool, deswegen bin ich hier
Bruss, was du nicht machen darfst
was es auch bei der letzten Folge noch nicht gab
du darfst nicht ChatGBT nach React fragen
weil das empfiehlt ja alle Sachen von vor anderthalb Jahren.
Ich frage vielleicht den ganzen Tag
ChatGPT meine React-Fragen.
Das ist aber super praktisch.
Ich meine, ich habe bisher echt wenig mit TypeScript gemacht.
Ich habe weniger mit TypeScript gemacht, als wir
in diesem Podcast über TypeScript gesprochen haben.
Das war mein
Ding, dass ich immer TypeScript rede.
Jetzt mache ich auf Arbeit kein TypeScript mehr und du machst
TypeScript oder was?
Ich kenne mich noch nicht gut aus in den Möglichkeiten,
die so existieren.
als ich das erste Mal allein schon über den
Spread-Operator gestolpert bin, musste ich mir
von ChatGPT erstmal erklären lassen, was zum Teufel
ich da gerade anschauen muss. Den gibt's in Swift
nicht? Nö.
Aber ich find's fancy.
Ja, super nice.
Bis du merkst, dass das alles shallow Copies sind.
Das hab ich sogar
mit ChatGPT sogar erklärt gehabt.
Das fand ich sehr nett.
Aber ich nutzte
das, ich hab einen ChatGPT-Thread,
wo ich ihm am Anfang mal gesagt hab,
wo ich dem Ding am Anfang mal gesagt
habe, ich habe keine Ahnung
von TypeScript, von React oder von Material UI,
was ich hier nutze, sei mal bitte meine
Debugging-Hilfe. Und seitdem frage ich einfach
jede Frage in diesem Thread und
dadurch, dass er jetzt schon sehr viel
Kontext hat, natürlich keine interne,
die ich in diesen Thread schreibe, aber
ich finde es geil.
Fragst du gerade
ChatGPT, weißt du was?
Would you rather identify as he or she?
Ich würde sagen, as a large language model.
Er denkt noch eine Weile drüber nach.
Sie denken noch eine Warte drüber nach.
Ja, aber genau das war ja meine Feststellung,
als du mir das erste Mal
in der SwiftUI gezeigt hast.
Ah, das ist witzig,
sieht genauso aus wie React.
Und bei Compose...
Ja, hier, as an AI-Language-Model.
I don't have a gender identity
or personal pronouns.
Ja, ja, war klar,
was da von der Antwort kommt.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich das,
was sie mal als allererstes eingetrichtert haben.
Erstmal so die Fragen
zu sich selbst beantworten.
Ja, auf jeden Fall
habe ich wirklich sehr viel Spaß
eine Web-Anwendung zu bauen. Das macht mega Spaß.
Bist du schon
beim Webpack-Einrichten
angekommen? Nö.
Dann hast du noch Spaß.
Cool, cool. Aber es ist halt,
also ich meine, ich bin ja gar
nicht das Dev-Tooling aus anderen Welten gewohnt.
Ich bin Dev-Tooling aus der iOS-Welt gewohnt.
Ich habe mit Xcode gearbeitet jetzt
seit Jahren und
jetzt nutze ich
VS Code. Ich habe Hot Reload, das
funktioniert. Es ist einfach so
flott und ich kann einfach
die gesamte...
Dieses Fight oder wie immer das heißt?
Ja, genau. Ich habe nicht ganz verstanden,
was das ist, aber ich dachte, es sei irgendwie bloß
eine Art... Oh, wir können so viel Spaß haben,
Kilian. Okay, okay, okay. Ich bin gespannt
auf die Zukunft. Wir machen anscheinend diesen Podcast
Beleben jetzt neu mit Kilian Lern-React.
Kilian Lern-Web-Dev.
Und ich muss sagen,
was ich mir... Also ein paar Sachen, die
mich sehr angehen, überraschen.
Zum einen, es hat mich
eine halbe Stunde ein bisschen fluchen,
und fünf Zeilen GitLab CI-Lamme gekostet,
dass ich diese Frontend-Anwendung einfach auf GitLab Pages,
GitLab Pages suckt hart, GitLab ist ein Haufen Scheiße,
aber das sei mal dahingestellt.
Und jetzt baut das einfach automatisch die Anwendung auf GitLab Pages
und ich kann immer den Live-Bild von jedem beliebigen Branch anschauen.
Nice.
Und das ist halt schon geil.
Das ist...
Also das geht halt mit iOS,
eine funktionelle CI für iOS ist hart.
Und bis ich für unser Setup auf Arbeit irgendwann mal
das zusammengefrickelt hatte, dass man
Branch-Builds hatte, die Ad-Hoc-Builds
waren, die du dann über
Enterprise, wie heißt das,
oh fuck, ein Ad-Hoc-Build halt
heißt so, dass du das halt auf dem,
du kriegst eine Seite generiert, kannst mit deinem
iPad auf diese Seite gehen, kannst auf den Link klicken
und kriegst den Bild von diesem Branch installiert, um das zu testen.
Bis das lief.
Boah, was ein Aufwand das war.
Das war ein fucking Aufwand. Es ging auch,
aber das ist natürlich bei Weitem nicht so bequem wie
hey Kollege, schau mal bitte auf diese
Webseite da, ändere mal
hinten den Pfad auf meinen Branch, so sieht die
Anwendung gerade aus. Wie nice ist das denn?
Das ist so geil. Das ist so
cool. CSS fuckt mich noch hart ab,
aber so cool.
Ja, ja. Also ich kann dir,
was nehmt ihr denn als Build-System?
Weißt du gar nicht.
Was führst du denn aus,
damit du siehst, was passiert?
NPM Run Build.
Und was macht das Run Build?
Irgendwas mit React-Scripts.
Ah ja, dann bist du wahrscheinlich bei...
Ich habe Create React App.
Okay, alles klar.
Create React App, das ist so ein Bootstrapping-Tool,
was dir erstmal so ein Setup gibt.
Und das kann man benutzen, dann irgendwann kann man Eject sagen
und dann hat man kein Create React App mehr,
sondern dann hat man auch so was wie Webpack.
Und ein Webpack sind Bilder und die Leute,
die jetzt schon anfangen, ihre Bleistiftische zu fetzen,
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich fange ja gerade erst an.
Ich habe da keine Ahnung.
Bei uns in der Firma haben häufig die Leute den Witz gemacht,
oh, du hast wohl dein, hast du jetzt deinen Webpack-PhD schon verdient,
weil Webpack super painful und umständlich ist
und immer mal sich komplett ändert und sowieso alles macht,
alles, nur genau das, was du jetzt gerade brauchst, nicht?
Und das ist super fricklich.
Ich habe jetzt auf Arbeit ein neues Projekt,
wo wir auch tatsächlich zum ersten Mal,
Also bei mir hat sich auch alles geändert auf Arbeit,
aber ich kann gar nicht so, ich weiß gar nicht,
ich muss nicht unbedingt ins Detail gehen,
aber unter anderem bauen wir ein Web-Frontend
für ein bestimmtes Feature, auch from scratch neu.
Das soll dann in eine native Desktop-App integriert werden.
In eine native App integriert werden.
Sprich, da kommt ein Webview rein,
wo dann dieses Feature angezeigt wird.
Genau.
Okay.
Also wir haben so eine Windows-32-Anwendung vom Vorwarnkrieg,
und zwar vom vorletzten.
Und das Beste, was man da machen kann, um irgendwie einen REST-Schnittstelle anzusprechen, ist tatsächlich ein WebView einbinden. Und es gibt bei uns in der Firma ein Team.
Das ist die most straightforward Variante?
Ja, du möchtest keine nativen Windows-GUIs von gewisser Klebkomplexität haben.
Das ist sehr wahr.
Und Portabilität heißt halt auch,
dass du diese Komponente vielleicht irgendwann
in eine tatsächliche Web-Anwendung,
die dann vielleicht der Nachfolger von der Nativen sein soll,
einbauen möchtest.
Und dann kommst du irgendwann in den Kosmos von Microfrontends.
Wo ich jetzt...
Kennst du Anwendungen...
Das ist ein schlechtes Beispiel,
sowas wie Microsoft Office Online.
Du loggst dich ein
bei Office und dann hast du
darunter Unteranwendungen.
Das sind keine Microfrontends,
aber du hast da Unteranwendungen wie...
Das ist nicht einfach nur ein Link zu einer anderen Anwendung.
Deswegen ist Microsoft Office ein schlechtes
Beispiel. Aber zum Beispiel
unsere Anwendung sieht so ein bisschen aus wie
VS Code. Du hast links so eine Leiste
mit Icons und jedes dieser Icons ist
eine eigentliche andere Unteranwendung.
Aber die sind alle in einer Anwendung
embedded und deswegen sprichst du von...
Und die sind alle embedded, werden
aber irgendwo
aus dem Netz gezogen und werden von
komplett unabhängigen Teams entwickelt.
Interesting.
Und das sind vielleicht
Microfrontends oder auch nicht. Anyway,
also wir bauen auch
ein so ein Feature und da bauen wir
ein React Frontend. Okay, cool.
Da war auch die Frage, nehmen wir
Material oder das hausinterne
Designkonzept und dadurch, dass unsere
Anwendung ja in die Win32
App von vorm Krieg, die eh nicht so aussieht.
Win95 CS.
Genau. Ja, habe ich schon vorgeschlagen,
wurde leider abgelehnt. Schade.
Genau.
Haben wir uns dann für Material entschieden,
was du ja offenbar auch benutzt.
Das ist schon voll fancy.
Und die beste Entscheidung, die wir getroffen
hatten am Anfang ist, dass wir kein Webpack mehr
benutzen, sondern VEAT.
Okay. Also ich habe viel davon gehört,
aber das ist
dann einfach nur ein Build System.
Also einfach nur in großen Anführungsstrichen.
Also das, was es unterscheidet,
ist, dass es in erster Linie ein Hoster und kein Bundler ist.
Ein Webpack.
Please explain.
Aha.
Bei JavaScript gibt es eigentlich keinerlei Modulsystem,
deswegen sind deine JavaScript-Anwendungen
alle zusammen in einen Blob gebaut worden.
Und dann lädst du dir ein JS runter
und da ist deine gesamte Anwendung drin.
Und das macht Webpack für dich.
Das ist so Modulsyntax wie Import from,
was bis vor ein paar Jahren
gar nicht Teil des JavaScript-Standards war,
für dich auflöst und
dir dann so
Komplexitäten abnimmt, wie, nehme ich jetzt
die Modulsyntax
AMD, UMD, die
von ECMAScript, die von TypeScript, die subtil
anders ist oder welche. Eigentlich ist es dir
völlig egal, du musst bloß zum Schluss eine Datei
mehr rauskommen. Das macht Webpack. Okay.
Und vielleicht benutzt du Webpack auch unter der
Haube, je nachdem kannst du mal messen, wie lange deine
Bildzeiten so dauern. Wenn es lange ist,
nimmst du wahrscheinlich Webpack und was dann
passiert ist, dass du deine Dev-Seite
lädst. Aber ist es nicht scheißegal,
wie lange die Bild-Seite ist? Also ich meine, gut,
nicht scheißegal. Ich komme ja aus einer Welt,
wo Bild-Seiten vor einer Minute
als gut angesehen werden und Bild-Seiten von
5 Minuten bis 10 Minuten sind schon
okay. Ja, wenn du Hot-Reloading
benutzbar haben möchtest,
dann macht das einen gewissen Unterschied.
Okay, fair.
Was Webpack zumindest
als Hauptaufgabe hatte, ist, dass es dir
deine gesamten Source-Tree einmal durchrennt,
alles auflöst, potenziell alles einmal durch irgendeinen Umwandler durchjagt,
wie zum Beispiel entweder TypeScript oder wenn du es schneller haben möchtest,
sowas wie Babel oder Bubble, wie du es ausbrechen möchtest.
Bubblefish.
Oder potenziell einmal durch einen Linter durchjagst,
obwohl du es in der Stage gar nicht machst,
der dann eine Datei daraus schnürt und die dann in deine eine Index HTML entbettet.
Und dann lädst du das neu und hast eine große Datei runtergeladen.
Aha.
So, und das macht Webpack und das macht Webpack auch super,
aber das ist eigentlich zu viel.
Und was Veed macht, ist, dass es dir eigentlich bloß deinen Code surft,
weil dein Code bereits mit ECMAScript aktuell geschrieben ist.
Und da ist Modulsyntax drin.
Und das heißt, deine Datei sagt, ich importiere das von dort
und der Browser kann das mittlerweile.
Man kann im Frontend Module nutzen.
Das heißt, es liegen mehrere JavaScript-Dateien, die der Web-Server surft.
Und wenn du eine importest, lädt dir einfach die andere nach.
Genau, genau.
Und das macht Veed für dich.
Das surft einfach all diese Dateien.
Und alles, was Veed noch macht,
also Veed macht noch wesentlich mehr, aber was Veed hauptsächlich
macht, ist, dass es in deiner...
Hier ist mal Fight ausgesprochen. Ja, ich denke auch immer mit dem E.
Was lustig ist, weil bei dem Fight empfohlen wurde.
Hallo, Fight.
Schönen Gruß.
Was Veed macht, ist, dass es dann einfach
noch diesen Hot Reloading Hook mit einbaut.
Das heißt, wenn sich eine Datei...
Es watcht alle Dateien in diesem Tree,
die du einmal runtergeladen hast,
löst es auf und wenn sich
eine davon ändert...
It's pronounced Veed.
Sag ich doch.
Und wenn sich eine Datei davon ändert,
dann wird halt ein Hot-Reloading getriggert.
Und das Schöne daran ist aber, du lädst dann nur diese Datei neu.
Das ist cool. Das ist echt cool.
Genau.
Ich finde es ein bisschen geil,
jetzt erst in Frontend WebDev einzusteigen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Welt vor zehn Jahren
noch ganz anders aussah.
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm, dass du jetzt erst einsteigst,
weil du hast ja offenbar das ganze
konzeptuelle Know-how
von iOS kannst du anwenden
zu einem gewissen Grad. Du kannst vielleicht noch ein bisschen
Input von außen mitbringen und den ganzen
Churn der letzten zehn Jahre,
da kannst du froh sein, dass du das nicht mitbekommen hast.
Ganz ehrlich.
Mir wurde bloß von irgendwelchen Leuten gesagt,
nee, warte, wer hat das gesagt?
Oh, von irgendwelchen Leuten. Meine Freundin hat mir
das gesagt.
Schön, gut.
Sie ist aber wahrscheinlich nach
der halben Stunde Sendung jetzt mittlerweile
auch schon eingeschlafen.
Das
React gar nicht mal mehr so der aktuelle heiße
Scheiß ist, aber das wird schon noch benutzt für neue Entwicklungen, oder?
Ja, React fühlt sich so einen Ticken an,
wie halt
das Enterprise Frontend.
Echt? Aber was mich vor allem begeistert hat,
gerade für eine neue Anwendung, ist, dass es nicht so
unglaublich viel Boilerplate war
und nicht viel Magie, sondern es war
sehr minimal und verständlich
und man konnte halt super schnell damit einsteigen.
Es war kein großer Haufen Scheiße in einem
leeren Projekt, wo man erstmal durchsteigen muss und das alles
so drumherum. Du fängst ja wirklich immer bei null an
und das Schöne bei React ist, dass es nicht viel mitbringt,
was halt doof ist bei React, ist, dass es halt
auch ein Ticken, also
was dazu führt, dass du React nach
zehn Jahren immer noch nehmen kannst, ist, dass es nicht sonderlich
opinionated ist,
aber ich mache immer den Witz, dass vor React
gab es halt alle anderthalb Jahre ein komplett neues
Framework und seit React
ändert sich einfach React alle anderthalb
Jahre fundamental. Das hast du letztens erzählt,
ich habe auch schon was gefunden, dass die früher so Klassenkomponenten haben
und jetzt alles so, in Anführungsstrichen
functional, was aber halt nichts mit
funktionaler Entwicklung, also alles war alles functional.
quasi Methoden-Syntag, also das ist jetzt
ein Hot-Tag, aber die haben quasi Klassen damit nachgebaut
und nur das Klassen-Keyword.
Ja, aber ich verstehe nicht, wieso.
Weil du plötzlich doch wieder stayed innerhalb
von dem... Ja, nee, das schon.
Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum sie von den Klassen weggegangen sind,
weil die waren syntaktisch, finde ich,
verständlicher, nachvollziehbarer, was da passiert.
Don't ask me.
Ich habe neulich...
Oh, kennst du Fireship,
diesen YouTube-Channel?
Nee.
Es gibt jetzt auf
Stack Overflow,
da gab es ein neues Entwicklersurvey
und da gibt es eine neue Visualisierung zwischen
was ist desired und was ist tatsächlich
beliebt.
Ich packe das Video dazu in die Show Notes
und da gibt es Sachen,
die sind tatsächlich
nicht beliebt,
aber desired oder
nicht desired, aber beliebt.
Ich kriege es nicht so ganz zusammen.
Naja, gibt es Hinsen, das ist beides, geht klar.
Aber React nimmt da auch so einen komischen
Punkt ein. Das wird ganz viel benutzt,
super populär, aber es gibt eigentlich auch Sachen, die
beliebter sind als React.
Zum Beispiel Svelte,
was allerdings dann das Paradigma wieder
umdreht. Also Svelte fühlt sich
reaktiver, aber nicht so funktional
an, weil du nicht, bei React hast du
eine Funktion, die dir UI
ausspuckt. Das ist schon, also wenn du
von Hooks, die alles auf den Kopf stellen,
wenn du von Hooks mal absiehst, hast du vorne
gehen Daten rein und hinten kommt UI raus.
So und bei, und du hast
aber witzigerweise, HTML mit diesem
JSX oder TSX hast du HTML
in JavaScript. Ja, was ich
sehr geil finde, muss ich sagen. Und bei
Svelte hast du es richtig rum, HTML,
deine Komponenten schreibst du in HTML und die
haben ein Script Tag und da
kannst du...
Ich verstehe es, das ist so ein bisschen so ein
Back-to-the-Roots-Approach auch. Das ist
ein syntaktischer, was man halt gerne mag.
Aber ich finde es ganz geil
mit JSX und TSX,
weil du halt syntaktisch limitierter
bist. Also nicht limitierter, aber
es lässt zumindest nicht so viel Bullshit zu wie in HTML
und das finde ich gerade als Newcomer in der Webwelt
mega nice. Du kannst damit komplett HTML schreiben.
Was soll denn damit nicht gehen, was mit HTML geht?
Nee, du kannst zum Beispiel nicht einfach
Bullshit-Tags schreiben, die HTML einfach
annimmt. Das ist bei
JSX und TSX nicht möglich. Doch.
Okay, dann hat die Doku gelogen.
Aber ich mag die Aussage.
Es erkennt halt, was für
Tags du
als andere, welche der Tags
andere Komponenten sind und die werden als Komponenten
gerendert, aber dazwischen kannst du ganz normales
HTML schreiben. Ja, aber keine invalide Syntax.
Du musst deine Texte, glaube ich, zumachen.
Ja, genau. Zumindest, das ist doch schon mal etwas.
Ja, aber du musst keine Texte nehmen,
die existieren, weil die könnten irgendwo...
Ja gut, fair, ja, meinen Wegen.
Und jetzt gibt es noch ganz andere Fässer,
die man aufmachen könnte, wo ich überhaupt nicht der Experte bin.
Es gibt noch weitere Frameworks neben,
also ich bin ja wirklich auch unbedarft,
es gibt noch so Sachen wie Solid
und Lit und
Preact, da müsste man mal jemand anders
einladen und eigentlich möchte man alles
mittlerweile nur noch mit Web-Komponenten bauen.
und da gibt es ganz viel
Webkomponenten.
Ist das Konzept von, du hast
Components wie in React, aber sind eigentlich
Teil des Webstandards und du solltest
weil React
baut ja nur einen Shadow DOM zusammen
und das ist eh eine ganz schlechte Idee.
Aha.
Bist du schon beim Shadow DOM angekommen?
Ich weiß von der Existenz des Shadow
DOMs. Das ist etwas.
Das ist noch nichts, was mir jetzt in meiner aktuellen
React-Entwicklung entgegengekommen ist.
Du hast mal noch Spaß.
Ja, ja.
Es ist auch mega geil, weil wir halt auf Arbeit auch
relativ viel 3D-Krams
im Web machen und
3.js beziehungsweise
React 3 Fiber heißt das, glaube ich,
ist einfach ein React-Wrapper um
3.js mit Komponenten. Da gibt es noch ein Framework
3, was irgendwie auch ein Teil davon ist.
Das ist so geil einzubinden.
Das ist so easy und dann hast du so einfach
eine Anwendung mit vollfunktionalen 3D-Komponenten
drin und wir haben ja
Erfahrung, diese 3D-Editoren
für Robotersteuerung zu bauen.
Und das im Web abzubilden, das hat
nicht mal einen halben Tag gedauert.
Das ist so geil. Das ist da einfach
plötzlich drin und dann
kannst du es bedienen und
ach, ich würde sagen,
ich finde es schon geil.
Als jemand, der bis vor wenigen
Wochen noch keine Ahnung hat, wofür
Frontend-Frameworks eigentlich da sind,
muss ich sagen, ist das schon irgendwie
ganz geil, was damit alles möglich ist.
Ich habe mich sogar schon dabei erwischt,
vorgestern oder gestern, mit der Idee zu spielen,
wie cool es wäre, eine Elektron-Anwendung zu bauen.
Ja,
bloß
dass halt Elektron dann halt noch eine ganze Menge
Rattenschwanz mitbringt. Ja, deswegen gibt es ja
coolere Sachen wie Tauri,
aber das ist noch nicht
meine Welt. Ich meine, ich will ja aktuell eine
Web-Anwendung bauen. Ich will kein React Native machen
oder eine Elektron-Anwendung
bauen, aber ich will eine Web-Anwendung bauen und dafür
ist es halt einfach super
angenehm. Ja, das Web ist eine supergeile Plattform.
Hätte man fast
denken können, dass das irgendwie mehr Leute
auf dieser Plattform Dinge aufbauen.
Ich möchte eigentlich behaupten, dass die meisten Leute
Sachen auf Webplattformen bauen, oder?
Zu Recht, merke ich gerade.
Also ich bin dann halt immer überrascht,
dass dann Leute diese Features in ihre
proprietäre Plattform zurückportieren,
damit das dann zum Schluss auf weniger
Geräten geht als vorher.
Ich schaue mal, wie lange es noch dauert, bis wir irgendwelche
Performance-Probleme haben und dann
schauen müssen, wie wir das wegoptimiert kriegen.
Das sind Sachen, in die du dann eh reinrenzt.
Aber du hast dich eventuell mit den
DevTools von Chrome schon auseinandergesetzt.
Nee, aber mit den DevTools von Safari.
Cause I'm a weird person like that.
Also
wenn ich, ich benutze
Firefox für alles, außer für Webentwickeln,
dann nehme ich Chrome einfach wegen der DevTools.
Das muss ich leider gestehen, ja.
Hauptsächlich auch, weil die
Anwendung, die ich bis dato am meisten debugged habe,
auch nur auf Chrome lief, weil
sie leider nur für Web-ATC-Features
nur genutzt haben, die Firefox nicht da waren.
Ich wollte vorhin noch was
dazusagen zu Pipelines. Du hast dich also
freut, dass man Pipelines bauen kann,
wo Zeugs... Achso, die GitLab CI Pipeline.
Bei uns seit der
Änderung bin ich jetzt auf GitHub,
auf einem internen GitHub und ein Team
von uns hat eine richtig, richtig schöne Jenkins Pipeline
gebaut. Ein GitHub Enterprise oder
ein Private GitHub?
Ein GitHub.com
Also ein Self-Hauschen? Nee, okay.
Slash ein ehemaliger Firmenname von uns.
Also Public GitHub.
Und warum eine Jenkins Pipeline?
Das ist man heutzutage noch Jenkins?
Die haben das zusammengebaut, aber die haben halt richtig
nice Sachen gemacht. Also du hast
Semantic oder
Conventional Commit
Checks mit drin. Du hast
Semantic Versioning eingebaut
in das Dings und du kannst halt...
Was heißt eingebaut? Die machen Automatic Version Bumps?
Äh, Automatic Version Bumps?
Sobald du auf Master merchst,
kriegst du einen neuen Release-Punkt.
Und macht das irgendwelche Analysis,
was API-Boundaries angeht?
Nee, das machst du alles anhand von Commit Messages.
Ah, okay. Auch cool.
Genau, und dann haben sie halt noch eingebaut,
dass du an unterschiedlichen Stellen entweder Release Deployments,
Debug Reployments, Feature Deployments und Stage Deployments machen kannst,
die ich nicht einwandfrei auseinanderhalten kann.
Aber was du vorhin meintest mit, oh, wir machen einen Branch,
dann liegt irgendwo auf einem Dings-Feature-Slay-Branch-Name-Slay-5
der Bild vom fünften Commit von dem Feature-Branch rum.
Und man kann sich das vorher angucken.
Das ist schon ziemlich nice. Das haben wir drei Tage
angehabt und dann haben wir es ausgemacht, weil es schon
exzessiv viel irgendwo in
S3-Buckets schreibt und wir das gar nicht so
häufig angucken. Aber wenn man
ab und zu manchmal einen Feature-Branch,
beziehungsweise wenn die
Branches kurz genug leben,
dann braucht man das auch nicht unbedingt, weil man
dann einfach sich den letzten
Stage-Build anguckt. Aber es ist schon ziemlich cool.
Ich finde das auch super angenehm.
Das macht einfach so angenehm,
darauf zu arbeiten, wenn man einfach mal das
eine Live-Version davon zeigen kann. Das war zumindest eines
der ersten Male, wo ich mir gedacht habe, hey, cool,
das ist was, wo ich
nicht in meiner Freizeit professionellere
Tools als auf Arbeit verwende,
sondern die machen,
die haben da Probleme gelöst, die ich
in meinem Hobby-Projekt noch nicht gelöst habe, nämlich zum Beispiel
Semantic Versioning Enforcen
mit so einem Bot. Die haben zwei
lustige, zwei lustige interne
Bots laufen, die auch in TypeScript geschrieben sind,
dein Code-Scan,
der eine heißt Comply-And,
das ist so eine kleine, das Logo ist so eine
Ameisel. Ja, es ist eine Ameise mit einem Polizeihut. Und der checkt, dass du, wenn du Feature oder Release oder wenn du das bestimmt taggst, dann musst du halt immer ein Ticket mit angeben für irgendeine Compliance.
Und der andere, ich weiß nicht, warum die getrennt sind, der andere ist dafür da, deine Commit Messages zu checken, beziehungsweise deine Pull Requests zu checken. Da haben sie einen Default, wo ich mich geweigert hatte, der Default war, deine Commit Message ist egal, aber dein Pull Request Title muss conventional Commit Message sein und der wird gecheckt.
und danach wird alles gesquasht.
Dann habe ich erstmal eingestellt, dass das nicht alles
gesquasht wird,
dass weiterhin deine Commit-Messages
richtig sein müssen
und du kannst bei GitHub noch einstellen, dass die
Merge-Message,
die Commit-Message von dem
Merge-Commit dem
ähm
dem Titel des
Pro-Requests entspricht. Okay. Das ist auch nicht
der Fall. Und seitdem, ich schreibe
jetzt in meine Commit-Message, äh
Pull-Request-Titel rein, Feature,
irgendwas, bla bla bla, Ticketnummer.
Und die Commits sind nur Refactor,
ich hab das geändert, Refactor, ich hab das geändert,
Refactor, ich hab das geändert. Und das sind die eigentlichen Änderungen.
Fix, ich hab das geändert. Und wenn es
gemergt wird, hast du einen Commit, der heißt Feature wurde
gemergt mit dem Ticket. Und auf jeder
einzelnen Code-Zeilenänderung steht aber
dran, Refactor, das geändert.
Bei VS Code siehst du ja, wenn du die Zeile anklickst,
die Commit-Message von wann die
das letzte Mal geändert wurden. Das ist eigentlich nur das GitLens.
Das ist, eventuell ist das GitLens.
Jeder hat GitLens installiert.
Und das ist tausendmal wertvoller als kommentieren,
weil du einfach siehst, was ist der Sinn dieser Zeile gewesen.
Ich würde nicht sagen, das ist tausendmal wertvoller als kommentieren.
Es ist schon definitiv sehr praktisch.
Was mir noch fehlt ist, du siehst immer bloß die letzte Änderung.
Ich hätte gerne dann pro Zeile noch so einen Log,
weil dann ist da, sobald da Refractorings drauf sind,
aber sieht man das nicht mehr.
Ein Kollege von mir hat regelmäßig den Linter maintained.
und auf
TypeScript benutzen wir
ESLint auch zum Formatieren und der hat dann immer mal,
wenn eine neue Prettier-Version rauskam,
alles umformatiert.
Und da habe ich gelernt, das packe ich auch in die Shownotes, es gibt
ein Setting in Git,
das heißt Git, Blame, Ignore
oder so ähnlich. Da kannst du dir eine Datei anlegen,
wo nur Git-Hashes drin liegen
von Commits,
die du beim Blame überspringen möchtest.
Ach, du musst explizit alle Hashes angeben.
Aber das heißt, solange du das
du machst ja nicht super viele
alles-um-Formatier-Commits, aber
solange du die explizit angibst, werden die
rausgetragen. Genau, du siehst, normalerweise würdest
du sagen, wer hat diese Zeile das jetzt mal angefasst?
Na, Martin, beim Formatieren.
Und wenn
du weißt, nee, nee, den Commit möchte ich nicht
sehen, siehst du den Commit von davor.
Das ist natürlich sehr praktisch.
Das ist schon nice, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist witziger, ich hätte ja irgendwie erwartet,
dass man aufgrund der
dass man irgendwie eine
Regex für die Commit-Message angeben kann, was da gefiltert
so, dass man
aufgrund dessen irgendwie filtert. Oh, das wäre natürlich
auch cool, vielleicht geht das sogar. Also ich meine,
es ist Git.
Du hast es dir gerade ausgedacht.
You can conceive of it, so it
must already be implemented in Git.
Es ist so ein bisschen wie, wie heißt das?
Rule 37? 4, ja.
Rule 34 in Git. If you need
a Git-Feature, it's already implemented.
Ist echt so. Und wenn nicht,
das ist irgendwie ein Einsider mit
irgendwelcher total obskuren
AWK-Syntax oder irgendwas. Auf jeden Fall.
auf jeden Fall.
Wollen wir noch über andere Projekte reden?
Mir fällt jetzt noch ein
Pick ein.
Das ist hier Picks Heaven.
Wir müssen aber noch ein bisschen warten, bis wir
zu den Picks kommen.
Naja, wir haben ja ein paar Sachen, die wir noch
ansprechen können. Ich habe gehört,
du bist jetzt reich, also du wirst
bald reich.
Wir hatten vorhin über Tauri
geredet. Tauri ist
hot. Tauri ist
richtig cool. Was ist Tauri eigentlich?
Was ist Tauro überhaupt? Du weißt,
dass Anwendungen
mit Elektronen bauen eigentlich cool ist.
Ja,
also ich muss gestehen, ich finde mittlerweile
die Idee, eine Anwendung mit Elektronen zu bauen,
super cool. Ich würde gerne die einzige
Person sein, die Elektronen nutzt, sodass ich
die Dev-Experience bekomme, aber sonst keine
Elektronen-Anwendungen auf meinem System sind.
Genau. Das finde ich geil. Aber ja,
Anwendungen bauen mit Elektronen ist ziemlich geil.
Sieht zumindest so aus. Und es gab vor einigen Jahren
schon mal andere Projekte, die hießen
Elektrino oder Neutrino
minimal, weil dein Betriebssystem
eigentlich schon eine
UI-Komponente in seinem nativen
Framework mitbringt, die dir Webseiten
Webinhalte anstellt. Das ist ja eines der Hauptproblem
von Electron, dass du in Chromium bundelst
und das halt
dann immer outdated ist, weil
es beim letzten Bild der App
da reingebundelt wird.
Dadurch hast du auch Chromium
in diversen
Anwendungen drin, wo du
nicht damit rechnest. In meinem Passwort-Manager.
in einem Kommandozeilen-Tool.
Was?
Es gibt von
Elec, das habe ich neulich erst verstanden,
es gibt von AWS
so ein Login-Tool.
AWS
Auth CLI oder so ähnlich heißt die.
Das gibst du ein.
Und damit du dich in dein
AWS einloggen kannst.
Und da geht so ein kleines Fenster auf, wo du deinen Benutzernamen
Passwort eingibst und dann geht das wieder zu.
Und die haben diese GUI in die CLI
eingebettet.
Und die muss aufgehen,
weil OAuth 2 voraussetzt,
dass du tatsächlich einen Browser aufmachst,
was ich nicht hundertprozentig verstehe, warum sie dafür Chrome
nehmen. Zumindest ist da wahrscheinlich kein
Elektron drin, aber die liefert Chrome mit aus.
Aber warum kann man das nicht im System
Browser machen?
Lass uns dieses Thema an dieser Stelle
unterbrechen. Aber krass, dass
die Elektronen eine CLI eingebettet haben.
Oder einen Chrome eingebettet haben.
It's not unheard of. Das ist beeindruckend.
Hätte ich nicht erwartet.
Krass.
Das Product Management hat gesagt, ja, wenn das das Problem löst,
dann mach das doch so. Easy peasy.
Und das Team ist danach wahrscheinlich woanders hin versetzt
worden und jetzt ist es halt so. Ich schätze mal, so läuft das.
Man kann natürlich solche Anwendungen auch mit
Systemkomponenten die Webkomponenten
darstellen können, machen. Also auf
Chrome benutzt es dann, würde man dann,
äh, Quatsch, auf Apple
würde man dann sowas nehmen, was
auf macOS würde man dann sowas nehmen,
was Safari embedded
und auf
Windows zumindest gibt es eine Komponente, die heißt
mittlerweile WebView2.
Das ist zumindest das, was wir in unserer
Windows-Anwendung kennen. Ist das Edge statt IE oder warum heißt das
WebView2? Das ist statt
IE Edge. WebView2
for you. Weil
Microsoft ja mittlerweile drei Browser
hat. Das ist wie die Ausweis-App 2.
Es gibt keine Ausweis-App 1.
Es gibt nur
die Ausweis-App 2.
Das klingt halt fortgeschritten.
Nein, nein, das klingt sketchy
as fuck. Okay, es gibt
den WebView2. Und
was auch immer es auf Linux ist.
Und Tauri ist einfach ein Rust-Framework,
was ist die Erlaubt-Discope-Anwendung zu bauen,
was ich noch nie probiert habe.
Und ich weiß,
dass es unter Windows WebView2 verwendet
und ich weiß, dass es auf
MacOS wahrscheinlich
Safari verwenden wird.
Und die Idee ist, dass du halt
The Power of Electron hast, ohne
dass du den Browser selber mitbringst.
und sie machen noch viele andere Sachen besser,
die Elektron doof macht insofern,
als dass sie für das Backend nicht einfach
einen Browser und einen Node.js zusammenknippern,
damit du alles in JavaScript machen kannst,
sondern ein anständiges Framework anbieten
und sogar eine sichere Kommunikation
zwischen WebView und deiner eigentlichen Anwendung
oder deiner eigentlichen Logik anbieten.
Aber da habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt...
Das ist eine sichere Kommunikation.
Ich verweise an dieser Stelle auf
andere Podcasts.
Aber
eine Frage noch kurz,
das nutzt kein Node-Server under the hood
für die
Backend-Logik,
sondern
die systemeigenen JavaScript-Execution-Tools?
Also wie es den
WK-Web für macOS dann wahrscheinlich nutzt,
nutzt es dann wahrscheinlich auch die JavaScript-Core?
In Node.js schreibst du,
äh Quatsch, in Electron schreibst du
Teile deiner Anwendung in
Web Framework, JavaScript und
Node.js JavaScript. Genau, du hast ja quasi
den UI-Teil und den Logik-Teil.
In Tauri schreibst du
den UI-Teil immer noch in deinem
Web Framework, deiner Wahl und JavaScript
und den anderen Teil in Rust. Ach so.
Ja.
Und weil
du da Sachen aus Rust machen kannst, die was
mit dem Operating System machen,
möchtest du Operating System
Fundamentals mit Rust bedienen können.
Und dazu gehören
auf vier Betriebssystemen auch so Sachen
wie Desktop-Notifications.
Da kenne ich ein praktisches Crate für.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du von der schon ausgehört hast.
Notify Rust heißt die.
Genau. Und da hatte ich
irgendwann vor Jahren, als wir noch an der Uni waren,
ich habe mal in den Gitlog reingeguckt, das ist wirklich
acht Jahre alt.
Die ist älter als der Podcast, oder?
Ja, definitiv älter als der Podcast.
Eines meiner ersten Rust-Projekte war,
ich möchte Catch My Buzz in Rust bauen.
Was braucht man als erstes?
Desktop-Notifications.
Keine Ahnung, ich brauch's ja bloß für Linux, also hab ich's für Linux gebaut.
Ein Kumpel von uns, Felix, hat dann irgendwann zum Spaß eine Mac-Library, die ähnlich ist, gebaut und die haben wir dann einfach eingebunden.
Und irgendwann, Jahre später, kam mir jemand von außen und hat gesagt, hier ist noch Windows-Support.
Und irgendwie hat's diese Library als Dependency in Tauri reingeschafft.
Und das war jetzt sehr lange ausgeholt, um zu sagen, dass jetzt in den letzten Tagen lustige Sachen in meinem Issue-Tracker von dieser Lib passiert sind.
Und zwar bauen Leute mittlerweile, dadurch, dass Tauri so beliebt ist, Anwendungen, die sie verkaufen wollen in Tauri. Zum Beispiel eine Firma namens Linen, die heißen auch wie, die sind auf Linen.dev und die verkaufen sich, aber ich habe sie nie ausprobiert und das soll auch wirklich keine Werbung sein, aber die Tagline hier auf der Webseite ist, Google searchable Slack alternative for communities.
Und das mit dem Google Searchable habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach die Tatsache, dass der Google-Bot den Content initiieren darf, was bei einer Slack-Community natürlich nicht geht.
Achso, ich dachte, es liegt darum, dass der Name Linen irgendwie...
Nee, es geht darum, dass der Content in deiner Community Google-Buy ist und somit, wenn du deine Plattform da hast, dass Leute über Google-Suche Fragen, die in deinem Chat gestellt wurden, finden können.
Ah ja, hier steht auch, Linen ist a real-time chat-plattform built for communities. We are SEO-friendly while providing modern chat-experience.
Das heißt, du kannst da drin rumchatten,
aber es ist definitiv alles offen im Internet.
Ja, aber das will man ja auch für eine Community.
Deswegen ist Slack ja scheiße für Communities.
Schon immer.
Slack hat dieses 20.000 Message Limits.
Slack hat ein Account pro Plattform, pro Community.
Slack hat keine Moderation Tools.
Slack ist eben nicht Googlebot-indizierbar.
Slack ist eher für Firmen.
Slack ist für deinen internen Chat.
Slack ist nicht für Communities gedacht.
Ja, das macht doch ein bisschen Sinn.
Und von der Hinsicht finde ich das ganz cool,
dass sie sowas bauen.
Und die bauen das auf Tauri auf.
Bauen das offenbar auf Tauri, denn der CEO
dieser Firma hat bei mir in meinem...
Ach, das ist der CEO?
Das ist der CEO von der Firma. Witzig.
Hat bei mir
und eigentlich habe ich es mitbekommen, dadurch, dass
mich von einer
Bug-Bounty-Firma jemand auf LinkedIn
aufgestellt hat. Was?
Das siehst du vor den GitHub-Notifications?
Ich muss gestehen, ja.
Hier, wir haben
ein Bug-Bounty auf deinem Ticket
so und so aufgemacht. Ich hoffe, das ist okay.
ich so, okay, was muss ich machen? Ja, nichts.
Also du kannst es fixen.
Zumindest ist auf einem Issue,
was seit einiger Zeit offen ist,
nicht das, das ist
auch offen,
auf diesem Issue,
was ominöserweise Magnification
is do not work,
heißt,
2022, das Issue ist nur minimal älter
als unsere letzte Folge. Das stimmt.
Das ist auch von vorm Krieg.
Da schreibt jemand, ich hab das hier mal
ausprobiert und es geht nicht auf meinem
Blackbook M1. Und
ich muss gestehen, ich kann es
nicht nachvollziehen und
es gibt hier mehr Details zu und irgendwann habe ich es einfach
liegen lassen, weil ich nie so viel Aufmerksamkeit
drauf hatte. Und dann hatte jemand
einen Bug-Bounty draufgestellt und ich sehe
gerade, das Bug-Bounty ist wieder weg.
Huch!
Das Bug-Bounty ist nicht mehr da. Das war doch erst
gestern oder so?
Das war gestern oder vorgestern, genau.
Und das Bug-Bounty ist nicht mehr da.
Und das Bug-Bounty,
aber auf einem anderen Ticket haben die Leute
selber noch ein Bug-Bounty draufgestellt.
Hier, ich lese es mal vor,
die Firma, die diese Bug-Bounties verteilt,
das ist halt so ein Mittelsmann, die heißen
Algorak
PBC. Also Algorak,
es ist so eine Plattform dafür, das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Genau. 300 Dollar
Bounty created by
Cheese Blubber.
Cheese Blubber ist der CEO
der Firma. Ich glaube ja.
Ich liebe ja solche
Usernames. Ich fand es auch damals richtig
weird. Du bist irgendwie jemand wirklich,
der irgendwo im Vordergrund von so einer
Multimillion-Dollar-Firma steht und hast
solche... Ich weiß, ob die so groß sind, aber
ich hatte auch mal einen Kollegen bei Apple damals,
der hatte den sehr weirden
GitHub-Username Acid Bomber.
Und das ist halt so,
du bist halt schon irgendwie professionell im Kontext
hier auch gange, aber
weiß ja nicht. Und Cheeseblubber ist einfach nur
süß. Ich meine, mein GitHub-Händel ist Hoodie,
das ist ein Kleidungsstück.
Und dein Name im Internet
immer. Und der Name
von dem JavaScript-Fail-Work, der wahrscheinlich wieder gestorben ist.
Das gibt es nicht mehr.
Also die hatten aber super schönes
Artwork. Die hatten Bilder von Hunden in
Hoodies. Das war wirklich niedlich.
Zumindest
kann man das... Also ihr könnt
gerne auf mein GitHub gehen und diese Issues
fixen. Also das eine kann man jetzt offenbar
nicht mehr einsammeln, weil man hat bloß
zwei bis fünf Tage, nachdem das Bounty ausgesprochen
wird, sich dieses Ding zu kreien.
Nee, nee, Payment arrives in your account
2-5 days after the Bounty is rewarded.
Ah, stimmt.
Also das bleibt so lange aktiv, solange die das
aktiv haben wollen.
Dann liegt es vielleicht daran. Aber dann bei dem
hier haben sie es auch...
Wenn man in maximal 5 Tagen die Change raushauen muss.
Die 300 Dollar sind ja schließlich
eine Menge Geld.
Ja, schon, aber es sind halt
auch nur 300 Dollar für
potenziellen Change, der halt alles andere
als trivial ist. Ich vermute mal,
das Problem, was du hier hast,
dass Mail-Notifications nicht funktionieren,
glaube ich, als jemand,
der sich vor jahren Jahren auf deine Wünsche...
Du weißt, dass du 200 Dollar für dieses Issue nicht mehr kriegen kannst.
Ja, ja, aber du hast mich ja vor etlichen Jahren
schon mal gefragt, ob ich mir das Issue anschauen kann.
Und ich behaupte, damals waren das halt schon irgendwelche
Bullshit-App-Kit-API-Issues,
also nicht API-Issues, aber du hast
auf macOS gewisse Limitierungen, wer Notifications
senden darf. Potenziell hat sich das
seitdem geändert, aber du musst halt eine App sein.
Du musst eine Infopilist haben,
du musst in spezifischen Directories irgendwie liegen,
du musst haufenweise Regeln erfüllen
und das tun halt viele,
vor allem CLIs nicht. Und das ist
kacke. Und da kommst du halt einfach nicht so
easy drumherum. Der easyste Weg
drumherum ist ein Tool zu nutzen,
was viele Leute installieren, namens Terminal
Notifier, was quasi einfach nur so eine
Forwarding, das ist eine
App, die drum liegt, die sprichst du an
und die schickt dann die Notification für dich, weil die eine
wirkliche App ist. Theoretisch kann man das sogar
einbetten irgendwie, aber das geht viel zu weit
für das Crate. Das ist
richtig eklig dann. Man müsste potenziell mal
schauen, ob das Ding open source ist, ob man sich das einfach klauen kann,
was die machen. Aber
Es ist auf jeden Fall alles andere als trivial
und bei weitem nicht so einfach wie auf Linux,
wenn du auf macOS Desktop Notifications schicken möchtest.
Es sei denn, du bist eine normale AppKit-App.
Dann ist es sehr trivial.
Also für mich war es super trivial,
weil wir hatten es ja damals selber gebaut, dieses Ding,
einfach irgendeine Notification Center API anzusprechen.
Und bei mir...
Außer du hast AppleScript genutzt, dann ist es auch trivial.
Nee, nee, nee, haben wir nicht.
Aber bei mir funktionieren Desktop Notifications
aus selbstgebauten CLI-Binaries immer.
Das ist ja das Problem.
Bounty ist ja jetzt weg, aber
hier haben seitdem noch drei Leute drauf
geschrieben, kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Und ich so, ja, that's why the issue
is open for so long as a bit of a Heisenberg.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was ihr habt.
Bei mir geht's. Aber du bist nicht auf einem Apple Silicon
Mac? Das ist mein Hauptproblem.
Vielleicht liegt es doch daran irgendwie.
Tja, da liegt der
kurz aus.
Aber ich meine, wir müssen jetzt hier nicht zu sehr
ins Detail gehen. Wir sind übrigens immer noch dabei,
diese Podcast-Folge aufzuzeichnen, aber
Das Witzige ist,
dass ich jetzt tatsächlich mal so ein Bug-Bounty
mir eingefangen hatte und die haben sich noch andere Sachen...
Einfach so eingetreten.
Das Witzige war tatsächlich bei dem...
Eigentlich noch witziger ist das neuere
Notification-Listener für Mac und Windows.
Und zwar ist es so, dass du...
First and foremost ist es eine Linux-Library,
weil die API,
diese D-Bus-API, die ich da anspreche,
relativ komplex ist und
das Windows und Mac ist eher so nachgereicht.
und die verlinken hier auf meine offiziellen
Docs und da gibt es hier
eine schöne Tabelle, die ich irgendwann mal explizit
hingeschrieben habe, da gibt es halt, du kannst
eine Notification wegschicken und dann hast
du einen Notification-Handle und auf dem
kannst du aufrufen
Wait for Action, Close, Unclose,
Update und ID.
Das gibt es alles nur auf Linux.
Und die wollen genau das für Mac und Windows.
Und die hätten das gerne für Mac und Windows.
Ja, aber du kannst nicht einfach, also
das, was AppKit nicht zulässt, kannst du dir
nicht einfach hinwünschen. Also es gibt
was, und hier ist
noch ein bisschen Room for Improvement, es gibt tatsächlich
ein, zwei Sachen, die
auch die Mac-Variante erlaubt, dass
man auf Notifications warten kann und dann haben die
hier irgendwas geschrieben von, dann blockiert halt
der Main-Thread die ganze Zeit, das könnte man
noch fixen. Aber so
Was sie doch wollen ist, dass wenn du auf den Button
eine Notification drückst, dass du was ausführen kannst.
Theoretisch kann das auch eine Mac-Notification.
Das Problem ist jetzt,
dass ich habe, dass ich eigentlich eher der Experte
für den Linux-Code bin und mir halt
Jahren den Mac und den Windows-Code eingetreten
habe. Den Mac-Code könnte ich mir noch anschauen,
obwohl das halt Objective-C ist.
Für Windows habe ich nicht
meine Plattform, wo ich in meiner Freizeit daran arbeiten
könnte an diesem Projekt. Warum auch?
Wer hat dann schon
privat einen Windows-Computer?
Wenn dann nur privat. Also ich habe meinen
Steam-Rechner. Das ist meine
Windows-Maschine. Ah, da komme ich mal mit dir vorbei.
Aber ich habe da letztens
mal versucht, Python zu installieren für irgendwas
und das war schon so, the fuck am I doing here?
Warum braucht man dafür
ein Installer, was passiert?
Vielleicht gibt es auch andere Möglichkeiten.
Da gibt es ein Tool, das heißt
Rai. Die coolen Leute heutzutage
nutzen wahrscheinlich alle das Windows Subsystem für Linux.
Anders ist Windows
ja auch nicht benutzbar.
Es gibt ein... Weißt du eigentlich, warum das so heißt?
Obwohl das eigentlich das Linux Subsystem
für Windows sein müsste.
Weißt du, der Name ist ja schon irgendwie
falsch rum. Weil immer Windows vorne stehen muss?
Sie durften nicht, also
die Legal-Abteilung hat gesagt, sie dürfen
nicht Linux an den Anfang des Projektnamens schreiben.
sondern müssen Windows vorhin
schreien. Und dann seitdem heißt es das
Windows Subsystem for Linux, obwohl das
Konzept-Dual komplett falsch ist.
Das ist schon...
Ah, ne.
Ähm, genau.
Das war
das Thema Bug-Bounties.
Also wenn ihr Lust habt mitzumachen, ihr könnt euch
300 Dollar verdienen.
Ihr müsst ein Dollar stehen, nicht Euro.
Cool. Nice.
So, jetzt haben wir Fahrrad-Stuff abgehakt.
Wir haben...
The fuck is Rosemary?
Oh, Rosemary.
Baust du dir manchmal selber Tools, die so einen Itch scratchen, weil du was brauchst?
Oft.
Ja.
In meinem GitHub, den wir gerade besprochen haben, habe ich zwei Tools.
Eins heißt Scrape.
Das ist ein schnell zusammengeklärtes Kommandozeilen-Tool.
Da gibst du als ersten Parameter eine Webseite an
und als zweiten Parameter einen CSS-Selector.
und dann kannst du
dann kriegst du alle Hits, die auf diesen
CSS-Selektor treffen, zum Beispiel
alle UR- und CSS-Selektor
ich weiß, du bist noch nicht bei CSS angekommen, aber
CSS-Selektor
Ich habe schon sehr viele Scraping-Tools gebaut
also CSS-Selektoren kann ich
CSS selber nicht
Genau, dann gibt es auf
GitHub-Hoodie-Scrape
Ich hatte letztens auch ein kleines Tool
auf Arbeit gebaut
Ich habe keine Doku dafür geschrieben, hier steht
Minimal Scraping-Tool for Personal Use
Und das ist wirklich einfach
generisch im Sinne von URL, CSS-Selector
und was machst du damit?
Ich habe damit auf Arbeit
die Artifactory-Download-Seiten
nach neuen Versionen gescrapt, damit ich nicht
weiß, weil du
hast ja so eine
hornalte, wir surfen einfach den Inhalt von
einer Verzeichnis-Seite und die
neuesten Bilder sind aber ganz, ganz unten.
Das heißt, du musst nach dem Refresher noch runterscrollen.
Das musst du nach dem Refresher noch runterscrollen
und das war mir irgendwann zu blöd und dann habe ich einfach
mir einen Scrape gebaut, wo ich
ein A ist gleich und dann
gibt es ja Tilde ist gleich
den URLs, die irgendwie grob
diesen String enthalten. Dann habe ich die aktuelle
Version, auf die ich weiter eingegeben und habe ich
entweder was geknüpft oder nicht. Das ist sehr cool. Genau, das
ist Scrape. Und du hast
aber gerade Rosemary gelesen
und kennst du das
Unix-Tool
Time? Das ist ein Bild in
die Shell meistens. Das ist einfach
die Dauer von
Ausführungen. Genau. Time
hat, wenn sie fertig ist.
Aber manchmal machst du Sachen, die dauern ewig und dann denkst
du dir so, wann ist denn der Scheiß endlich fertig?
Darf ich nur zu? Sorry, aber erzähl das mal.
So, Rosemary macht das beim ersten
Durchlauf, ich hab hier sogar so ein GIF gemacht,
macht beim ersten Durchlauf das ähnliches wie Time,
es zeigt zum Schluss, dass das jetzt 10 Sekunden gedauert hat
und es merkt sich, wie lange der letzte
Bild von dieser Aufführung
gelaufen ist und rendert dir während es
läuft eine Progress Bar,
die dann so lange läuft, bis
diese Zeit vom letzten Mal... Ach, das merkt
sich quasi, also dass das
Du kannst jetzt deine Anwendung bauen und wenn das Bauen
immer so grob 25 Sekunden dauert,
dann zeigt es dir halt die nächsten Male.
Wie betätigt das, wenn du es mehrfach ausführst?
Ich hatte vor, noch ein bisschen mehr
Logik einzubauen, aber momentan merkst du es wirklich nur,
was du als allerletztes gemacht hast. Finde ich aber schon mal sehr cool.
Da hast du zumindest ein Gefühl dafür, wie lange
das dauert. Genau. Ich habe
letztens mal tatsächlich einen sehr ähnlichen Itch gehabt
und mich hat es genervt, dass ich häufig
im Hintergrund meiner Bureau-Updates
gefahren bin und
Bureau-Updates sind ein schlechtes Beispiel, aber auch
andere Log-Running-Commands, von denen ich auch
wissen wollte, wann sie fertig sind. Und
gerade wenn die halt mehrere Sekunden oder
sogar Minuten dauern, dann achtet man da einfach
nicht drauf. Und da,
weil ich schon lange kein irgendwas
Shelliges mehr geschrieben habe und dafür immer
ChatGPT frage, weil es einfach tausendmal einfacher
ist, habe ich ChatGPT gefragt, hey,
schreib mir mal einen Hook, der mir eine
Desktop-Notification schickt, wenn der aktuelle
Shell-Command länger als 10 Sekunden dauert und fertig
ist. Und seitdem habe ich das in meiner Z-Shell-Konflikt
drin und das klappt mega nice.
Wenn irgendwas länger als 10 Sekunden dauert, wird
automatische Notification gefeuert, wenn es fertig ist.
Womit feuert er die Notifications?
Mit Terminal Notifier, eben direkt.
Das habe ich mit AppleScript gemacht,
wo du einfach nur über osaskript-e
ein Skript angeben kannst,
aber da war das Icon hässlich.
Ich wollte ein Terminal Icon.
Und das kriege ich mit Terminal Notifier
geschecken.
Ähnliche Ideen,
Problemdomäne, aber
Rosemary sieht sehr schick aus.
Meine Notification-Lib ist auch in so ähnlichen Tools drin.
Da gibt es irgendwie irgendein Alert-Tool,
was du, wenn du denn was ausführst, hinten dranhängen kannst.
Oder vorne dran.
Das könnte ich hier theoretisch auch machen.
Dass ich zum Schluss noch eine Not...
Warum mache ich das denn nicht?
Okay, nachher.
Stark.
Aber ich liebe solche, wie du schon meintest,
solche Probleme, die einfach so ein Itch scratchen.
Das ist auch definitiv...
Es ist immer sehr zufriedenstellend,
wenn man da was gebastelt hat,
was genau dieses eine kleine Problem
fixt. Wir haben auf Arbeit
Was
Was sehe ich hier gerade?
Download-Zahlen von
irgendwas?
Ach, das sind die Dependents von deinem Notify Rust
Crate. Genau, das war mal ein Cargo
Watch. Es ist in Tauri eingebaut?
Es ist in Tauri eingebaut, deswegen
habe ich ja so viele Downloads.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
Deswegen habe ich ja irgendwie schon eineinhalb Millionen Downloads
auf diesem Dings.
Das ist wieder erstaunlich wenig dafür,
dass es in Tauri eingebaut ist, oder?
Oder ist Tauri einfach noch so klein und unbekannt?
Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht nicht.
Es ist zweimal in Tauri eingebaut, in Tauri und in Tauri API.
Eigentlich war mein größter User Starship.
Kennst du Starship?
Nö.
Ach doch, das war so ein Shell-Prompt-Dings, oder?
Genau, Starship.
Genau, das habe ich, glaube ich, schon mal erwähnt gehabt.
Die heißen Starship.rs, das benutze ich jetzt auch.
Damit habe ich eigentlich eins zu eins
meine
Z-Shell-Prompt
nachgebaut.
Das sieht jetzt also.
Mein Prompt hier, das da,
dieser eine kleine grüne Punkt
und ein Tilde mit dem Ordner
ist Starship,
aber das sah vorher bei Satchel bei mir schon genauso aus.
Mein Satchel Prompt ist nicht
konfigurierbar. Ich verstehe das nicht mehr, was
in der Konfigurierung steht. Genau, aber
das Coole an Starship ist, du hast
eine Top-Datei, deine ganzen einzelnen
Einträge, da sind irgendwelche Plugins.
Okay.
Und es ist...
Der Execution State vom letzten Command?
Genau, du kannst jetzt, wenn ich jetzt hier was eingebe,
was kaputt geht,
dann ist bei mir der Punkt rot vorne vom vorherigen Mal.
Dann hast du das aktuelle Verzeichnis und du hast am rechten
Bildschirmrand noch ein paar
Git-Daten wie den letzten Tag wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe den aktuellen Tag.
Sag bitte, dass die Krabbe davor irgendwie
Sprache im aktuellen Directory ist.
Das sagt mir an, dass das die aktuelle
Rust-Version ist, die hier drin geht.
Ach, das ist die Rust-Version, die da geht.
Das ist der Branch.
Dann kann ich anzeigen, wie weit ich dem Master schon
voraus bin.
Da zählt sogar Zeilen.
zählt Zeilen?
Find nach
FindPipe,
nee, Find,
achso, das ist ja
Live-Coding
im Podcast ist schon starten.
Nach TestPipe, dann habe ich eine neue
Datei und dann müsste ich hier irgendwie
äh,
dann zeigt er mir
hier an, dass ich Dateien
ungetrackt habe und
jetzt eingecheckt habe und wenn ich
Okay, also quasi der Git-State
vom aktuellen Directory in schöner Icon-Form
zusammengefasst. Genau.
Und das Schöne ist, es wird live geupdatet, wenn du
diese Konfigurationstommel-Datei änderst.
Hot Reload für Shell Prompt.
Aber wie
macht der das? Ich weiß es
nicht.
Das ist ja fancy. Also er rendert nicht die
Leinen neu, aber sobald sie... Ach so, ach so.
Okay, gut. Gut, damit kann ich
leben. Weil alles andere hätte mich hart irritiert,
wie es um Teufel das geht. Aber was mir
neulich erst aufgefallen ist, anyway, ist,
ich bin jetzt hier in einem Projekt
drin, NotifyRust, witzig, haha,
und der zeigt
mir eigentlich den Pfad, in dem ich bin.
Und jetzt zeigt er mir aber an, NotifyRust
slash source slash hints, weil ich in den Ordner
gerade reingegangen bin. Mein PWD
ist aber eigentlich ein längeres.
Und der zeigt mir, der schaut,
in welchem Git, wo ist das
nächste Git-Verzeichnis nach oben, zeigt mir das
als root an und dann innerhalb
von dem den relativen Pfad zu dem Git.
Damit der nicht zu viel von anzeigen muss.
Genau, weil wenn ich jetzt die
Verzeichnisse hochgehe, siehst du, dass plötzlich
dann was anderes da steht. In dem Moment, wo du das Git-Verzeichnis
verlassen hast, zeigt dir, da wird es... Sobald ich ein Git-Verzeichnis
betrete, steht nur noch das Git-Verzeichnis vorne.
Das finde ich auch sehr cool. Das ist nice. Zumindest, warum
ich auf Starship umgestiegen bin, ist, weil ich
plötzlich auf Arbeit ab und zu mal auf Windows
arbeiten muss. Und das gibt es auch für PowerShell.
Und dann siehst du jetzt plötzlich, dass PowerShell...
Du weißt nicht, wo du mein Windows-Devon-Wire-Mind hast.
Ich kann ja auf dem Arbeitskiste nicht
an, wenn ich ein Open-Source-Projekt von mir persönlich arbeite.
Aber ich habe mir
dort ein Starship eingerichtet, das sich
so ein bisschen wie zu Hause anfühlt.
Aber du bist in der PowerShell.
Krass. Ja, ich kann dort auch auf
Bash umsteigen, aber ich habe tatsächlich
PowerShell-Skripte für die CI gebaut.
Oha. Ich habe schon erzählt,
dass ich auf Arbeit jetzt eine kleine Rust-Bibliothek
baue, die ich in eine Windows 32
Anwendung einbette. Ist das für die
besagte Anwendung? Das ist für die besagte Anwendung.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob
sie lange drinbleiben wird, aber momentan
habe ich einen ganz schön Aufhebens gemacht, um sie dort
reinzukriegen. Ich benutze zwei unterschiedliche
CI ist eine, mit der ich eine besagte
schöne Jenkins-CI, die ich gerade auch erzählt habe,
die mir so Sachen wie Compliance
und Conventional Commits und
Releasen und Bauen
auf Linux und Testen und
potenziell auch Container Deployen macht.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass ich aber
eigentlich für Windows bauen muss und auf Windows
ist das Einzige, was diese Pipeline nicht kann, weil sie
komplett auf Docker basiert. Und dann habe ich
mir zusätzlich zu dem Jenkins, was wir haben, auch noch ein
firmeninternes TeamCity, was von
JetBrains ist, angeschlossen. Stimmt, das gab es ja auch.
Und das TeamCity zieht jetzt von dem GitHub
und baut das ganze Ding nochmal auf Windows.
Und dann muss ich aber das gesamte Build-Environment,
was ich haben möchte, nochmal dort nachbauen.
Anyway, das geht jetzt auch zu weit.
TeamCity hat da eine erstaunlich schöne Oberfläche.
Okay, habe ich noch nie in Action gesehen.
Ich möchte nicht viel Gutes über TeamCity sagen,
aber das Web-UI von TeamCity gefällt mir besser als das von Jenkins.
Gut, du vergleichst mit Jenkins, das ist unfair.
Also, das ist
Punching Down.
Entschuldigung.
Ja, das war mein Pick Starship.
Sind wir schon bei Picks?
Da gehen wir jetzt einfach zu den Picks über, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, wir sind einfach zu den Picks.
Was hast denn du so für Picks?
Ich habe mir
nur zwei Sachen hier auf die Liste
gesetzt, weil ich dachte, wir gehen
sinnvoll damit um und dann hast du plötzlich 20 Picks
dazugeschrieben.
Nee, die kann ich auch irgendwie
in der nächsten Woche, in der nächsten Folge mit rein.
Alles klar.
Gut, ich habe mir ein paar Sachen auf die Liste gesetzt.
Unter anderem zum Beispiel ein Firmwork,
was ich tatsächlich auf Arbeit erst entdeckt habe,
jetzt vor ein paar Tagen, namens Streamlit.
Das ist ein Toolkit für Python-Entwickler,
um Web-Apps zu bauen.
Und da fällt am Ende quasi eine kleine React-Anwendung raus.
Aber das ist halt erstaunlich schick,
weil das ist halt für Leute gedacht,
die irgendwas mit Daten machen.
Also im Sinne von, du hast deine Pandas-Frames, du hast Daten in Python und du willst die visualisieren. Und die haben eine erstaunlich schicke API für eine erstaunlich schicke kleine Web-Anwendung, die du damit bauen kannst.
Da fällt dann so eine Art statisches Frontend raus quasi?
Oder nimmt es dann irgendwie
eine Python-Panda-Geschichte als Backend?
So sicher bin ich mir gerade gar nicht.
Ich habe es noch nicht benutzt. Ich habe es bisher gesehen.
Ich will es mal ausprobieren die Tage.
Aber es sieht von der API zumindest
sehr schick aus und bietet dir
coole Möglichkeiten, wenn du jetzt mit Data Science
was am Hut hast, das Zeug richtig schick
rauszurendern, ohne dann auf irgendwelche
typischen Rendering-Sachen
zurückzugreifen, wie du baust
einfach eine Grafik mit Matplot-Lib und willst das
irgendwo einbinden. Ich kannte
bisher nur von anderen
exploratory Projekten, dass man
einfach dann ein Jupiter-Notebook
irgendwo veröffentlicht.
Jupiter-Notebook?
Spricht man das Jupiter oder
Jupiter aus, was mit Y ist?
Ich würde es ja trotzdem Jupiter nennen.
Das klingt sinnvoller.
Das bleibt nicht so mal, als stecken wir Jupiter.
Aber das hier ist echt schick.
Also das, was die in den Demos
haben, beziehungsweise was die in der Anleitung
zeigen, das ist schon echt hübsch.
Und das finde ich cool, dass sowas möglich ist.
Du kannst dann auch noch ein bisschen drumherum bauen
mit Python.
Hast du Konfetti?
Weiß ich nicht, aber ich habe Konfetti.
Nice.
Ja, das ist mein Pick Nummer 1.
Ich würde es mal gerne mal ausprobieren die Tage,
wie das wirklich funktioniert.
Aber es sieht schon echt fancy aus.
Nice.
Und erstaunlich populär.
Es hat 25.000 Stars auf GitHub und ich habe noch nie was davon gehört.
Gut, das heißt nicht so, dass Dinge unbedingt
auf meinem Teller landen müssen, aber
ich habe es einfach noch nicht auf den Job gegangen.
es gibt ja diese ganzen Bubbles, jede Programmiersprache
ist seine eigene Bubble und dadurch, dass du wenig
Python gemacht hast, hast du die riesen Python-Sachen
alle nicht mitbekommen. Ja, ich habe vor ein paar Tagen
ein Issue in meinem DVB-Pyrepo bekommen,
dass es nicht mit Python 3.10 läuft
und jetzt habe ich... Jetzt gibt es schon 3.11.
Hui, das wusste ich nicht mal.
Ich bin wirklich nie in der Python-Bubble.
Ich wollte die Tage mal
eine OpenAPI-Spec
für die DVB-APIs schreiben
und dann einfach den Client da rausgenerieren.
Da muss ich den nicht mehr selber mentieren.
Das klingt gut.
Veed brauche ich nicht mehr in meinen Picks
auflisten. Vermutlich nicht.
Fireship haben wir eh schon
in der Liste von Sachen in den Shownotes,
weil wir es vorhin erwähnt haben.
Ein Tool, wo
ich festgestellt habe, oh,
das hätte ich gerne früher schon gehabt,
ist, und ja,
mir haben auch Leute auf Twitter schon beschrieben, das kann man
auch mit Bordmitteln machen.
Git Absorb. Kennst du Git Absorb?
Git Absorb, nee.
Mit Bordmitteln, natürlich, weil du hast es ja...
Also man kann das auch mit, man konnte das vorher schon mit Git machen,
aber ich habe mir durchgelesen, wie man das mit Git machen konnte
das ist so ein bisschen wie
we have Git Absorb at home
ich hab's
ich bin froh, dass es Git Absorb gibt
aber es geht auch ohne Git Absorb
was zum Geier tut es
und zwar versetze ich einmal in die Situation
du bist ein Entwickler
oh, da kann ich mich reinversetzen
ja, es ist übrigens
ganz ganz kurzer Attention
benutzt du dieses
Rollenpriming
GPT selber.
Nee.
Wir hatten ein Keynote auf dem Mobile Camp gehört,
wenn du ChatGPT benutzt, ist es sehr effektiv,
wenn du vorher ChatGPT sagst.
Du bist ein mit Erfahrung in
und deine Motivation ist...
Das war mir zu viel Prompt Engineering Fuckery.
Anyway, ich prompte dich jetzt mal.
Setz dich in die Situation.
Du bist ein Entwickler.
Was kann ich?
Was weiß ich?
Du benutzt Git und du programmierst ordentlich.
Du planst deine Comments.
Du hast ein bisschen Kost davor,
einen Pull-Request aufzumachen.
und du hast bereits
fünf Commits auf deinem Branch, die du nicht
squashen wirst, weil du ordentliche Branches
der Reihe nachgeplant hast.
Wenn ich ordentlich arbeite, würde ich squashen, aber das ist meinungsvoll.
Anhand deines
Pull-Requests,
anhand der Commits, darin kann man deine
Arbeitsschritte ordentlich
nachvollziehen, was du in welcher Reihenfolge gemacht hast.
Ja.
Und jetzt stellst du aber fest, entweder du
bekommst noch Review und sollst was ändern
oder du hast so noch Sachen, die du ändern möchtest.
Du möchtest aber eigentlich, dass jeder Commit,
den du bereits hast, diese Änderung bereits enthält.
Also du hast im ersten Commit Datei A,
im zweiten Commit Datei B und im dritten Commit Datei C angefasst
und du möchtest die Änderung, die du jetzt überall nochmal machen musstest,
dass die irgendwie sich sinnvoll auf diese Commits
bereits, dass die da reingesquasht werden.
Ja, aber das ist ja schon irgendwie so ein
Das klingt nach so einem Squash, der
mehr Semantik beinhaltet, wo du halt wirklich
drüber nachdenken musst, wie du das, also
das kann ein Tool für dich übernehmen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie Gitabsorb das macht.
Es schaut sich wahrscheinlich an,
es geht durch jeden einzelnen
Hunk durch.
Du addest erstmal, du staget erstmal
deine Änderungen, die du absorben möchtest.
Und dann sagst du Gitabsorb.
Und dann geht das wahrscheinlich jeden einzelnen
Hunk von deinen gestagten Änderungen
durch und schaut,
was ist denn der Commit im aktuellen
Branch, wo das am ehesten
das letzte Mal angefasst wurde.
Okay, da ist schon Magie.
Und dann macht es erstaunlich viele
Fix-Up-Commits, quasi für jeden
Hang einen Fix-Up-Commit,
teilweise mehrere Fix-Up-Commits
mit derselben Commit-Message.
Bei manchen sagt es dir, da weiß ich nicht,
wo ich das hin tun soll, das musst du selber machen.
Und dann kannst du
Git Rebase Interactive
Auto Squash machen
und dann hast du deine
hast du deine Änderung, die du nachträglich gemacht hast,
minutiös ordentlich in die richtigen Commits einsortiert.
Das finde ich tatsächlich sehr ansprechend.
Und ich will gar nicht wissen,
wie viel Fuckery das beinhaltet,
sowas mit Gitboard-Methods zu machen.
Sagen wir es so, es ist, glaube ich,
nicht sonderlich viel komplexer, aber komplizierter.
Weil die Syntax, die du an die Kommandozahle von Git-Rebase
reinschmeißen musst, dafür einfach komisch ist.
Also jemand, der mit Interactive Rebases gerade so klarkommt.
Nee, danke.
Also ich habe mir irgendwann diesen Blogpost oder einen von den Blogposts durchgelesen,
die da heißen Plan Your Commits.
Und seitdem ist es so, wenn ich relativ viel durcheinander gehackt habe,
dann gehe ich hinterher nochmal hin und entweder fange ich nochmal bei 0 an
und mache es in einzelnen Commits.
Oder ich introduziere es zumindest so, dass jeder Commit sagt,
was ich genau in dem Commit geändert habe.
Das mache ich auch.
Ich stage dann Interactive das raus und versuche da halt das zusammenzuziehen,
was halt wirklich semantisch Commits sind.
Es sei denn, es ist so
verworren, dass ich das nicht mehr überblicke und dann mache ich die Augen
zu, komm mit der Eier auf einmal,
schluck die zerbrochene
wieder runter
und versuche nicht mehr darüber nachzudecken.
Da muss ich schon sehr verzweifelt sein. Ich fange dann teilweise wirklich nochmal
an und cherrypicke mir auch Sachen raus
und mache, dass es ordentlich ist. Weil ich
versetze mich in denjenigen, der das reviewen soll
und dann habe ich es am liebsten, auch wenn
du hast ja manchmal so
riesen Commits.
Bei dem Review schauen Leute doch eh bloß auf das gesamte Change,
in dem Image-Request, oder?
Niemand geht die Kommits einzig durch.
Also es hängt immer von deinem Team und deinem Projekt.
Aber manchmal, und bei mir ist es momentan auch so,
dass jeder im Team an was komplett anderem arbeitet
und wir uns das gegenseitig einfach nur so durchwinken.
Aber ich war zum Beispiel lange Zeit
Maintainer von einer relativ großen internen Lib.
Und da habe ich darum gebeten,
dass die Leute mir die Riesen-PRs,
die sie an 35 Stellen aufmachen,
so machen, dass ich die in einzelnen
Kommits nachvollziehen kann.
Das ist cool, wenn das auch machen.
Haben sie nicht immer gemacht.
Anyway, man möchte ja
ich sag mir immer, be the change you want to see
und deswegen versuche ich das so vorzuleben
und das selber so zu machen, wie ich gerne
Co-Reviewen würde
und deswegen benutze ich Git Absorb
Das klingt cool
Ich hab auch noch zwei Picks
Zum einen, wenn wir schon bei
GPT sind
das andere GPT, nämlich
Apples Gameporting Toolkit
Oh, das sieht ziemlich
krass aus
Es hat ein paar witzige Show-Comments, aber
ist jetzt nur interessant für Leute,
die Spiele spielen wollen und auf macOS
leben. Apple hat
jetzt auf der letzten Entwicklerkonferenz
das sogenannte Gameporting-Toolkit vorgestellt.
Das heißt wirklich GPT.
Leute.
Wir machen jetzt auch was mit GPT.
Ja, Siri wird besser, endlich. Nein.
Sie haben quasi
Proton
für macOS ins Leben gerufen.
Das, was Valve jetzt schon seit Jahren baut.
Bloß leider in...
will ich sagen in shitty, weil es geht schon in die
richtige Richtung konzeptuell, aber Apple
limitiert es halt stark mit
LegalFoo. Man hätte jetzt...
Du darfst es nur zum Testen benutzen
und zum Schluss musstest du es dann doch auf Metal portieren.
Genau, du kannst dein Spiel
zum Testen damit ausführen,
sehen, wie cool es laufen könnte,
wenn du es nicht portest
und dann darfst du es aber nicht für irgendwas anderes
nutzen, sondern du musst dann dein Spiel endlich porten.
Und ich hoffe, dass sie in Zukunft noch ein bisschen
sinnvoller damit umgehen, aber mein eigentlicher Pick ist
eine kleine CLI namens Orion
Und das ist einfach nur für die Leute auf der anderen Seite, nämlich die Leute wie ich, die Spiele spielen wollen, die können mit Orion das Gameporting Toolkit nutzen und damit ein Spiel einfach auf ihrem Mac starten, was sonst nicht laufen würde.
Nice, das muss auch ein Windows DirectX Spiel sein oder wird das für das Windows? Wie funktioniert das aber aus? Für das Windows Binary ist es aus?
Gameporting 2-Bit explizit ist an sich
ein Fork von Crossover,
was ein Fork von Wine ist.
Also die Crossover-Leute, das ist
eine Firma, die maintain Crossover schon seit
Jahrzehnten, glaube ich. Das ist an
sich ein optimiertes Wine
für Gaming. Also
für Leute, die auf Mac gamen wollen.
Aber was bei Crossover
noch nie konnte, ist DirectX 12
vor allem. Und das ist jetzt
explizit das, was Apple hier mit eingebaut hat. DirectX
12 Support, also quasi ein Metal-Gym
für DirectX 12.
Und damit laufen halt ziemlich moderne Sachen ziemlich cool. Also in dem Screenshot, beziehungsweise in dem Screen Recording in der Readme hier von Orion starten sie Elden Ring, was wirklich mit einer guten Framework auf macOS läuft. Und das ist halt ein sehr aktuelles Spiel auch mit. Und es macht halt schon so ein bisschen Hoffnung, dass vielleicht macOS-Spiele in Zukunft nicht mehr so nicht existieren.
Ja, ich hatte mir Steam auf die Kiste hier getan
und dann festgestellt, dass die Spiele, die ich spielen wollte,
alle für, entweder für Mac existierten,
aber auf meinem nicht liefen, weil es eine 32-Bin-Binary war,
was noch so ein Trauerspiel ist.
Oder es gab nur Windows-Binaries von Spielen wie Mass Effect oder sowas.
Das ist super traurig.
Dafür ist Gaming on Linux mittlerweile eine ziemlich schicke Sache geworden,
dank Proton vor allem halt auch.
Also ich bin ja auch Part-Time-Linux-Gamer,
dank dem Steam-Decks, behaupte ich einfach mal.
Iron Arch, by the way, aber nur Handheld.
Aber
also das macht ja schon Spaß,
was da wirklich, wie gut es auch laufen kann.
Das ist ja auch keine fantastische
Hardware, aber du kannst
halt da wirklich moderne Sachen
halbwegs sinnvoll spielen.
Das ist richtig cool, das Plattform.
Muss es ein M-Mac sein?
Ach so, hierfür?
Für das Gameboarding-Tool bitte sicherlich, ja.
Nee, so viel zu Orion.
Finde ich cool, dass Leute das gerade ein bisschen in die Hand nehmen
und Apples Lizenz-Shit halt
also nicht umgehen, aber
du hast dann die ganze Zeit auch dieses
FPS-Overlay relativ groß in der Ecke, weil
es halt explizit dafür gedacht ist, dass Leute halt das nur
zum Evaluieren nutzen. Aber du startest damit quasi einfach
das Windows-Steam und dann denkt das
auf, ich bin ja auf Windows. Genau, du startest damit
Windows-Steam oder einfach die Game Binary
selbst. Was witzig ist, gerade bei Elden Ring
gibt es so ein kleines witziges
Problemchen, nämlich
ist es selbe wie bei Proton.
Anti-Cheat klappt häufig
nicht bei solchen Emulators.
Es sind ja keine Emulation-Layers, aber bei
solchen Shims, weil
Anti-Cheat halt denkt, du startest da gerade sonst was
für Shit, obwohl es mittlerweile auch
Anti-Cheat-Zachen gibt. Weil du die Binary modifizierst.
Weil du die Binary irgendwie...
Ich weiß nicht, auf welcher Ebene.
Da kenne ich mich auch nicht mit ERC. Also mit Easy Anti-Cheat
ist das, was die meisten nutzen. Das ist ja glaube ich sogar von
Valve, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Ne, ist es nicht.
Oder doch? Ich weiß nicht. Es gibt
Easy Anti-Cheat, ERC, das nutzen die meisten
Spieleentwickler und das klappt theoretisch
auf Linux, aber in Praxis selten, weil
die Spieleentwickler zu doof sind, das richtig einzubauen.
jedenfalls ist das
meistens das Problem, was dich daran hindert, das zu
nutzen und gerade im Beispiel von Elden Ring
scheitert das halt auch an Easy Anti
Cheat, was du aber machen kannst, um
Easy Anti Cheat zu umgehen,
ist, die eigentliche Binary von
Elden Ring ist halt ein Easy
Anti Cheat Binary, die Elden Ring
startet, was daneben liegt und wenn
du einfach die Elden Ring Binary
umbenennst auf, das ist das
Spiel und die Anti Cheat
wegnimmst, dann startest du direkt das
Spiel. Dann klappen zwar die Multiplayer-Features nicht,
aber das Spiel startet ohne Easy-Energy.
Was ich schön low-tech
Workaround finde und dann läuft das Spiel
halt tadellos in
GPT-slash-Crossover-slash-Wine.
Aber cool.
Wenn es geht, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich will
coole Spiele spielen. Ich bin nicht die Person,
die Elden Ring spielen will.
Das ist nicht für mich, aber...
Ich spüre echt mit dem Gedanken,
ob es sich nicht lohnt, sich so ein
Mac Mini M2 nur zum Spielen zu holen,
wenn sowas geht. Das ist aktuell
noch nichts, was
jemand so sagen würde, aber vielleicht
in Zukunft. Ja, das Problem ist
halt, dass dieser Hardware leider
so gut ist, dass es schade ist, dass es keine
Spiele darauf gibt. Ja, vielleicht
ja in Zukunft mehr.
Wer weiß. Das haben sie schon häufig gewollt,
aber bisher ist es halt nicht passiert und
es liegt halt zum einen auch ein bisschen
mit daran, dass, also
gut, Mac-User sind in der Minderheit
auf dem Markt, vor allem auf dem Gaming-Markt,
aber ich behaupte, sehr viele amerikanische
vor allem Studenten haben Macs
und das war eigentlich schon immer eine recht große Sparte von Leuten
die man ansprechen könnte, auf der anderen
Seite sind in dieser Nische von
Mac-Usern halt immer noch
sehr viel weniger Leute, die
Gaming-Capable-Macs
haben, in Anführungszeichen, und jetzt mit
den ganzen Apple-Silicon-Maschinen sind halt die
meisten Macs, in Anführungszeichen,
Gaming-Capable, weil du keine
Mini-Intel-Macbook-Rs
mehr, so viele hast, da draußen
und mit der Zeit steigt dieser Faktor
einfach halt an von Leuten, die halt wirklich Spiele
spielen könnten auf ihren Macs und hoffentlich
wird das dann im Markt. Ich weiß nicht,
ich will einfach irgendwelche Strategiespiele auf meinem
Mac haben. Gimme, gimme. Und gib mir
das Starfield, das neue
Skyrim, Space Skyrim auf meinem Mac.
I want it. Sonst spiele ich das auf meinem
Steam-Windows-Rechner zu Hause. Es geht auch.
Oder auf dem
Iron Arch, by the way, device.
Aber ich will es auf dem fucking Mac spielen.
Gimme.
Cool. Ja, was hast du noch als Pick?
Oh!
Eine Sache, die ich unbedingt ausprobieren möchte,
das ist glaube ich auch das letzte, du hast mich so ein bisschen
vom Kaltenerbescheher, das ist eigentlich schon wieder aussortiert.
Und zwar gibt es
ein Framework
Library
Tool, wo ich mir denke,
ach, ich müsste nochmal so eine Diplomarbeit schreiben.
Das wäre jetzt wirklich cool.
Und zwar
Wie kommt man auf diesen Gitarren?
Tybst.
Ich verstehe deinen Gedanken.
Typst
Compose
Papers Faster.
T-Y-P-S-T geschrieben.
Compose Reports
Faster.
Compose Papers Faster.
Das ist quasi
zum ersten Mal seit einigen Jahren
ein wirklich legitimer Versuch,
Latex zu ersetzen.
Ich mag Latex sehr,
aber das Tooling ist scheiße.
Die Sprache ist auch scheiße.
Alles daran ist scheiße, aber das, was rauskommt, ist geil.
Das, was rauskommt, ist ziemlich cool.
Und Typs hat jetzt hier sich hingestellt und gesagt,
die werden, glaube ich, auch von irgendwelchen EU-Geschichten mitgefördert.
Die haben zum einen eine Sprache, die cleaner sein soll als LaTeX.
Die haben einen Side-by-Side, nicht Visi-Wiki-Editor,
aber so einen Preview-Editor, der ziemlich snappy ist.
Aber das Projekt an sich ist erst mal ein Typesetter wie Tech.
Es ist ein Typesetter.
Aber die haben auch einen Editor, den sie zusätzlich bereitstellen.
Ich glaube, den Editor, den kannst du eventuell ist der zu kaufen.
Ach so, okay.
Und das ist explizit dazu gedacht, dass du Typesetting für IEEE-Papers oder Reports oder wissenschaftliche Arbeiten machst.
Die sehen auch dolle danach aus.
Und die Capabilities davon sind halt wirklich eher in der Richtung LaTeX, weniger in der Richtung Markdown.
Also als ich meine Diplomarbeit geschrieben habe, habe ich das in LaTeX gemacht.
aber ich habe eigentlich 90% in Markdown geschrieben
und das mit Pendoc umgewandelt
und dann mich die meiste Zeit damit auseinandergesetzt hat.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie viel deiner Arbeit hast du da,
dass die Pipeline das tut.
Meine Vermutung ist, dass die meisten Leute
sich irgendwie 90% der Zeit mit dem Bildsystem
ihres Linux, ihres Latex-Setups auseinandersetzen.
Ich habe ja nie eine Abschlussarbeit geschrieben,
aber für die Sachen, die ich in Latex damals getypt habe,
in der Uni-Zeit, da waren auch Travis-Zeiten mit getabt
und da habe ich auch versucht, in den Travis CI
immer ein LATIC-Environment zu
instanziieren, was von
haus aus irgendwie nicht wirklich existiert hat.
Irgendwann gab es da mal jemanden, der einen Container bereitgestellt hat
und dann konntest du darin das bauen,
aber das hat halt die Ressourcen hart ausgeschöpft.
Zum einen, was Speicherkapazität
in dem Container anging.
Ich habe für das ASCII ein Tool gebaut,
was mit LATIC dann Dokumente erzeugt hat.
Ach, das ist ja Invoice.
Und ich denke mir, das hier ist übrigens,
ich muss auch wieder gestehen, es ist in Rust geschrieben,
das heißt, es gibt es als Library und ich habe,
ich spiele echt mit dem Gedanken, dem Invoicer einfach
das Typesetting-Feature inhärent
beizubringen, anstatt ihm dazu zu bringen,
Latex zu mit
Handlebars zu konkatenieren und dann
irgendwie... Das heißt, du brauchst auch
für den Typesetter ein Latex-Environment selber was?
Also in diesem
ASCII-Tool, was ich damals gebaut habe,
musste Latex diverse Pakete,
die mir gar nicht so richtig bewusst sind, installiert sein.
Und dann war das
Projekt in der Lage,
Latex-Code
als Handlebars-Template
auszufüllen und
dann LaTeX draufzuwerfen.
Genauer, SciTech oder eins davon.
Ich meine, das klingt nicht so verkehrt.
Das ist praktisch, davon abgesehen, dass du
mindestens drei Gigabyte LaTeX-Pakete
auf deinem System installiert hast.
Das ist natürlich scheiße, ja.
Aber die Idee, dass mit dem LaTeX-Template,
weil das ja ein sehr spezifisches Problem war,
du wolltest Invoices schreiben und das ist ja was, wo du
wirklich ganz spezifische Elemente in den
Template einfügen möchtest. Genau.
Also wenn ich mit demselben Handlebar einfach
diesen selben Text in das PDF hätte
einpasten können, wäre auch cool.
Ja, aber du hättest natürlich auch eine HTML
rausgenerieren können und die einfach zu einer PDF
drucken.
Anyway.
So habe ich damals dieses Formular gemacht für die
Arbeitszeiten der Fassung.
Und das muss man dann mal im Browser drucken und das sieht wie bei jedem
ein bisschen anders aus.
Ja, es sieht schon aus wie das Formular.
git.io.shk
ist die Short Domain dafür. Das war das,
wenn du in der Uni gezwungen wirst, Arbeitszeiten
zu erfassen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das überall
ist aber auf jeden Fall an der TU Dresden,
dann führst du da deine Arbeitszeit ein, deine wochentliche
Arbeitszeit und dann füllt der automatisch
randomisiert diese Formularseite
aus und dann kannst du
Command oder Control-P drücken und dann drückt der
das Formular aus.
Das Problem, also ich
argumentiere ja schon seit Jahren, dass
das Latix sterben soll, dass man alles mit HTML
machen soll, aber es ist leider
so, dass es bei
HTML immer noch nicht, also
please correct me if I'm hopefully wrong,
dass man bei HTML nicht 1 zu 1
sagen kann, wie das dann zum Schluss auf Papier
mappt. Es ist halt kein
Typesetter. Nee, das ist nicht das, wofür
es geschaffen wurde. Genau.
Hier gibt es mittlerweile sehr schickes
Formel-Rendering in JavaScript.
Ja, es gab schon vor
20 Jahren MathML
in Browsern. Das ist echt alt schon.
Dann wurde es wieder ausgebaut und das habe ich neulich gelesen,
es gibt so Twitter-Bots, die
veröffentlichen, was in Chrome oder Firefox
demnächst wieder eingebaut werden soll.
Das wird eingebaut, Dirk?
Jetzt wird MathML in die Browser wohl wieder mit eingebaut.
Geil, finde ich cool.
Ja, anyway, Tipps.
Es hat eine Standardbibliothek,
es besteht nicht einfach nur aus Makros,
es ist nicht so schön wie Markdown,
aber dafür ist es irgendwie konsistent.
Du musst ja wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
mehr Features als Markdown haben,
wenn du professionelles Typesetting machen möchtest.
Das Problem bei Markdown ist,
es ist schick, aber who's Markdown as it anyway?
Das kommt auch noch dazu.
Dann hat man, wenn man das,
Also ich habe meine Diplomarbeit in
Pendoc-Style-Markdown.
Pendoc-Flavor-Markdown geschrieben.
Und zum Beispiel so Sachen wie
Bilder mit Untertiteln.
Alt-Tags?
Achso, Dings.
Warte, hier gibt es
in der Referenz.
Nicht Figments, du willst.
Gibt es Figures.
Figures?
Also zumindest, aber wenn du Text haben wolltest.
Es kann Emoji.
OMG, sold, fuck Latech.
Tipps des Ways.
Wenn du Texte
mit Unterschriften und Blöcken
unter Bildern haben wolltest, kann natürlich Markdown
nicht. Das hätte es mit HTML vielleicht hingekriegt.
Aber in dem Sinne habe ich dann
Markdown geschrieben mit Embedded Latech.
Und das
Pendoc konnte das Markdown übersetzen
und das, was es nicht übersetzen konnte, ist dann halt Latech
geblieben und dann hast du es hinterher nochmal durch Latech gejagt.
Und dann hat es funktioniert.
Aber das klingt nicht so blöd als Ansatz.
ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig beim Schreiben zu wissen,
was am Ende rauskommt.
Die Art und Weise, wie ich das geschrieben habe, fand ich gut.
Irgendwie, dass du vornehmlich
Markdown schreibst, bis du halt mal was
Komplexeres brauchst, dann nutzt du
ein mächtigeres Tool.
Aber die Art und Weise, durch was für
eine Art von Bildsystem du das dann durchpipen musst,
Markdown, also Pendock ist ja
nur eins, danach hast du bloß Latex
erzeugt, aber selbst das Latex weißt du nicht, wie du es
bauen kannst, weil du musst es entweder mit
Latex, Seitech,
Luar-Technik oder einem
davon bauen, dann hast du
immer noch kein
Referenzverzeichnis. Dazu musst du es dann
mit BibTechnik dreimal bauen.
Also es tatsächlich gibt Aufrufe,
dass du BibTechnik irgendwie auf dieselbe Datei dreimal
aufrufen musst, weil er beim ersten Mal nur eins,
beim zweiten Mal nur das zweite und beim dritten Mal dann alles
macht.
Das kannst du einfach heutzutage keinem mehr zunennen. Also kein
Mensch weiß mehr heutzutage, warum zum
Geier sind solche Tools mit Präprozessoren
gebaut, die du mehrmals aufrufst.
Das ist aus Zeiten, wo halt du
100k Speicher
hattest und deswegen immer
zwischendurch alles auf die Platte schreiben musstest und deswegen
dir nichts, du hattest keinen RAM.
Ja, deswegen hat sowas wie 10
Pre-Prozessor, der einfach bloß Textersetzung
macht und dann alles kompiliert,
weil sie einfach nicht genug Speicher
für eine große Lookup-Table hatten.
Schon stark. Anyway, wenn ihr gerade
eine Diplomarbeit schreibt,
schaut euch Tipps an.
Auf jeden Fall. Erzählt mir, ob ihr es scheiße
fandet oder ob ihr vielleicht dann hinterher verlängern
musstet, weil er...
Wenn ihr gerade den letzten Monat vor der Abgabe seid
und nur die Motivation habt, am Tooling zu
arbeiten und nicht an der eigentlichen Arbeit,
dann schaut euch das Tool mal an.
Lattich ist super. Macht Lattich weiter.
Es sei denn, ihr schreibt gerade in Word.
Dann schaut euch das mal an.
Ich glaube, da muss man sich sowieso
über ein paar Lebensentscheidungen noch mal Gedanken machen.
Es gibt Studiengänge, wo das ganz normal ist.
Ich höre das ja auch
prinzipiell okay.
Anyway, das waren meine
meine Pics, das waren auch deine Pics.
Den Rest nehme ich mir für nächste Folge auf.
Akronomisierbar Edition
2023.
Wir sehen uns 2024
nochmal.
Ich hatte überlegt, ob wir uns potenziell in dieser
Folge prophylaktisch verabschieden,
falls es die letzte wird. Aber ich muss schon
sagen, irgendwie habe ich Bock auch nochmal weiter aufzunehmen.
Also es war jetzt eine Weile irgendwie bei mir so ein Tief
und bei dir vielleicht auch so ein Tief und irgendwie
man muss auch immer mal was Neues machen.
Ich habe Bock.
Der Podcast ist noch nicht tot.
Der schläft nur vielleicht noch mal.
Also das war akronomisierbar Folge 54.
Es war uns eine Freude und bis hoffentlich bald wieder.
Auf jeden Fall. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Jetzt kommt der nächste Podcast in eurer Playlist in?
Drei.
Zwo.
Eins.